[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
abobo est officiellement lancée à
l'automne
non le blanc pour poursuivre notre
lancée avec noir c'est seulement la
pratique consommateurs qui peuvent
remplacer justin trudeau qui pouvait se
battre pour vous c'est le npd um accordé
votre confiance jamais vous n'aurez le
regretté le vote avec le plus de pouvoir
c'est un beau terre
les autres partis ont de bonnes raisons
d'avoir peur de nous les canadiens vont
faire un choix
quelle direction ils veulent prendre
pour le pays
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en direct du musée canadien de
l'histoire à gatineau le partenariat
canadien pour la production des débats
vous présente le débat des chefs 2019
voici patrice roy bonsoir bienvenue à ce
débat des chefs
madame messieurs les chefs bonsoir à
vous vos places sur la scène et l'ordre
de parole ont été déterminées au hasard
cinq thèmes seront abordés ce soir
chaque thème sera lancé par une question
d'un citoyen en direct après la réponse
des chefs
il y aura deux confrontations à 3 puis
des questions en rafale de journalistes
invités ce débat sera suivi par des
citoyens ici au musée de l'histoire à
gatineau
on vous remercie messieurs dames d'être
ici et partout à travers le pays des
rassemblements ont été organisés
c'est le dernier débat de cette campagne
vous le savez je compte sur vous madame
messieurs les chefs pour nous donner des
réponses claires et surtout ne pas tous
parler en même temps j'y verrai
d'ailleurs vous verrez parfois
apparaître à l'écran le temps de parole
cumulatif des chefs
madame messieurs bon débat
[Musique]
premier thème environnement et énergie
et nous commençons ce thème de trois
rivières ce soir avec une question
d'elisabeth darveau madame darveau
bonsoir à vous ben ça alors madame d'art
volées chef vous écoute votre question
dans une ère où nous sommes de plus en
plus touchés par la cause
environnementale et où l'onu a déclaré
l'urgence climatique
il devient urgent de prendre les
dispositions nécessaires pour contrer
cette crise
ma question est la suivante sachant que
si nous n'agissons pas maintenant nous
atteindrons le point de non retour qui a
le premier changement concret comptez
vous faire pour protéger l'environnement
merci madame vers vous premier à
répondre justin trudeau
merci les abeilles pour pour votre
question mais c'est une question qu'on
entend à travers le pays depuis
plusieurs semaines au sillonnent le pays
pour parler aux gens qui justement nous
disent l'avenir de leurs enfants
l'avenir de l'environnement les plats
lutte contre les changements climatiques
c'est essentiel et on a beaucoup fait
sur 4 ha mais on doit continuer et on
doit pouvoir tenir tête contre elle ces
conservateurs comme jason kenny tom ford
et les pétrolières qui les appuient pour
pouvoir justement continuer de lutter
contre les changements climatiques y
bâtir un monde meilleur
c'est pour ça que le choix que vous
faites ce soir est si important mais
pourquoi aussi j'ai confiance dans les
canadiens j'ai confiance dans les
prochaines étapes qu'on va entamer
ensemble
merci monsieur trudeau monsieur bernier
bonsoir les autres partis vous disent
qu'ils vont atteindre les cibles de
l'entente de paris mais ils ne pourront
pas les atteindre puisqu'il faut imposer
une taxe sur le carbone de 300 dollars
la tonne pour ce faire et ils ne le font
pas et où s'ils disent qu'ils vont
sauver le monde sauver le climat
mais comme vous savez les émissions
globales du canada représente seulement
2,6 pour cent des émissions totales
nous au parti populaire on veut se
concentrer sur des gestes concrets pour
l'environnement s'assurer que nos eaux
soit dépollué note sal notre ère et je
pense qu'on peut réinvestir pour
protéger réellement l'environnement et
pas être hypocrite comme les leaders ici
autour de moi qui disent tout faire pour
aider les changements climatiques mais
dans le fond
non pas de solution monsieur singh merci
elizabeth
c'est vraiment grand danger je sais
qu'au québec on a eu des inondations
sévère on a eu des feux dé forêt c'est
vraiment un impact réel qu'on fait face
est ce moment on a eu des milliers d
enfants dans les roues dans ce qu'on
propose dès maintenant pas comme ce trou
d'eau qui a acheté un pipeline on veut
annuler tout de suite tu les subventions
pétrolière s'assure une aide à bord on
peut prendre tout de suite et on peut
réinvestir l'argent dans l'énergie
renouvelable dans l'énergie propre
aussi on veut réinvestir massivement
dans le transport en commun
on peut agir c'est un question de
d'avoir le courage on a le courage merci
monsieur singh monsieur oui
l'environnement c'est un des enjeux
central de cette combine et comme père
de cinq enfants
je veux assurer que nous lasse les
prochaines générations une environnement
plus propre que nous avons hérité mais
malgré ce qui prétend justin trudeau sur
sept dossiers
son plan est un échec une des premières
décisions qu'il a pris comme des
premiers ministres d'autoriser de
déversement de 8 milliards de litres
d'eau vous est dans notre fleuve
mon plan à mettre fin au déversement
d'eaux usées parce que nous sommes en
merci monsieur cher monsieur blanchet
mais bien le bonsoir merci de nous
recevoir chez vous encore ce soir
il ya certainement beaucoup de mesures
qui doivent être prises je vous à
mentionnerait quelques-unes je pense que
le parlement devrait par le biais d'une
loi un peu comme le suggère monsieur
singh son intention faire en sorte que
on sait ainsi immédiatement toute espèce
de subventions aux industries
pétrolières c'est autour de 10 milliards
par année au total sur une étude des
critères en 2018 ça vous dire quelque
chose dessus trudeau et un autre loi
pourrait faire en sorte de contraindre
de contraindre le canada a respecté ses
cibles parce que pour l'instant les
sites de 2009 de messieurs chers sont
devenus les cibles de monsieur trudeau
et rien n'a été fait pour les atteindre
il ya des mesures incitatives en termes
d'électrification des transports qui
peuvent être faites en laissant
d'ailleurs si monsieur je sais tout le
temps vous aviez madame mais en termine
à merci c'est vrai
exactement ce que vous avez dit nous
sommes maintenant trop proche à un point
de non retour
on doit éviter le pire maintenant on
sait seulement les verts qui a un
programme qui à aline aligné avec les
scientifiques du giec mais on doit
travailler ensemble pour mieux qu'anvers
c'est essentiel de mettre sur pied un
gain cabinet de guerre comme dans le
deuxième guerre mondiale de faire les
choses ensemble parce que on doit
éliminer les dépendances mj facile et en
même temps être changé notre économie
verte des premières merci madame mais
madame d'art vous trois rivières
j'espère que vous êtes éclairé en tout
cas c'est les réponses qu'ils vous ont
donnés merci beaucoup de votre
participation s'est apprécié merci merci
à vous alors premier trio première
confrontation à 3 il y aura madame et
monsieur trudeau et monsieur blanchet en
jeu depuis kyoto s'est il y a trente ans
les politiciens promettent de diminuer
les gaz à effet de serre pour atteindre
les cibles de paris le directeur
parlementaire du budget estime que la
taxe sur le carbone qui est de 20 $
actuellement la tonne doit grimper à 102
dollars d'ici quelques années ça pour
être très concret pour les gens la
maison c'est 23 sous de plus prend les
de décence monsieur blanchet vous êtes
d'accord avec le sang de madame et vous
proposer 200 vous monsieur trudeau est
ce que vous attendez après les élections
pour afficher votre prix non sûr on a un
plan pour monter ce prix là jusqu'à 50
dollars la tonne jusqu'en 2022
mais ces chiffres 200 $ 200 dollars la
tonne c'est si y'a rien d'autre qu'un
prix sur le pétrole -quelque un prix sur
la pollution
nous on a choisi de faire bien d'autres
choses aussi
protéger la nature encore plus
d'investir dans de finir avec les
centrales de charbon de bannir le
plastique à usage unique de planter deux
milliards d'arbres aussi que ça prend
énormément d'efforts pour le faire mais
on va le faire parce qu'on on a fait
plus déjà que tout autre gouvernement
dans l'histoire du pays pour protéger
l'environnement et contre les
changements climatiques le débat est
ouvert
ouais merci mais le problème c'est
lequel ce n'est pas suffisant de parler
seulement de prix sur crown
on doit mettre sur pied les cibles qui
sont alignés avec l'avis des
scientifiques et maintenant ce n'est pas
le troc pour son auto sur le niveau de
2005 par 2030 les cibles de monsieur
tout de même cible que monsieur harper
il est absolument insuffisant on doit
mettre sur pied a plein de verve
élimination des énergies fossiles par
2050 et pas 2030 60 % de réduction de
gaz à effet de serre et c'est vraiment
possible notre club s'appelle mission
possible parce qu'il reste possible ce
n'est pas facile mais il est possible
mais ce n'est pas avec seulement des
taxes carbone
je ne demanderais d'être plus précis oui
il faut arriver à ce que le seul pétrole
qu'on utilise soit du pétrole qui ne
sera pas utilisée à combustion assassin
à autre chose un peu il faut mettre une
date là dessus une fois que nos mines
date il faut calculer c'est combien de
réduction par année dans l'extraction
dans le transport dans l'exportation et
dans la consommation
il faut pas dire on va en parler en 2030
en 2025 il faut dire qu'on commence donc
c'est moins 3% l'année prochaine
-3% l'autre et ça exclut évidemment
d'aller chercher le 173 milliards de
baril pétrole qui reste en alberta c'est
totalement exclu sur la taxe à
proprement parler nous on a proposé ce
qu'on appelait la péréquation verte
moyenne des émissions à travers le
canada les provinces qui sont tous tu
paies cette taxe et celles qui sont en
dessous reçoivent cette taxe c'est
strictement administratif aucun
changement constitutionnel n'est requis
pour médecins en oeuvre et ça pourrait
faire une mesure très incitative et tout
le monde cette initiative me blanchet
souligner
des grands défis que vous avez en tant
que chef du bloc québécois c'est que
pour imposer un plan pancanadien ça
prend un gouvernement prêt à le faire à
tenir tête contre jason kenny contre les
pétrolières contre d'oxford contre ces
politiciens conservateurs qui ne veulent
rien faire pour l'environnement et on
n'est qu'à three scission des bons de
nouveaux dépôts pour protéger
l'environnement qui veulent lutter qui
ont fait beaucoup au courant des quatre
dernières années
on en a fait énormément mais on
reconnaît qu'il faut continuer c'est
pour ça qu'il faut pas arrêter faut que
les québécois que les francophones que
les canadiens fassent partie d'un
gouvernement qui veut lutter contre les
changements climatiques
la vraie réalité c'est que la situation
maintenant c'est une situation d'urgence
climatique
je parle de fond de mon coeur parce que
le tronc prince et maintenant tous les
autres chefs ici dont la scène avec moi
il n'y a personne avec un plan qui
marche pour éviter le pire
contact mme bragg a raison notre maison
est en feu
comment osez-vous mais surtout sur le
pipeline litres d'eau sur le pipeline
monsieur chirac est clair dans la
campagne il pourrait imposer un pipeline
vers l'est ce donc qui traverserait
entre autres le québec
vous avez pointé qu'elle n'y a pas de
projet il peut avoir demain matin un
projet sur la table
pourriez vous oui ou non imposer un
pipeline ça fait partie d'un processus
qui doit avoir l'approbation des
communautés l'approbation des peuples
autochtones de travailler avec avec les
avec les scientifiques pour assurer
l'impact et on va procéder comme on a
procédé avec l'oléoduc trans maintain
pour essayer de chercher l'approbation
et pour le faire de façon rigoureuse
les gens savent faut pas avoir plus de
pétrole par rail ça déjà c'est très
dangereux et plus polluants faut pouvoir
mettre les profits de ce qu'on a besoin
maintenant parce que la transition ça se
fait pas tout de suite vers l'énergie
verte vers la lutte contre les
changements climatiques et chaque dollar
de profits ira justement pour vous
proposer 2 e les éléphants public pour l
oléoduc temps en situation d'urgence
publique en urgence climatique
on doit arrêter tous les oléoducs
arrêté le gaz de schiste partout au
canada si on a cette chance d'éviter le
pire c'est dont l'avis des scientifiques
cdpa en question de les cibles en
politique c'est une question de la
réalité blanche il faut deux choses le
québec veulent pas est ce que vous allez
dire au québec non il y aura pas de léo
duc au québec et la deuxième chose si on
fait des propositions voulu trouver
bonne votre seul argument c'est ne peut
pas les mettre en place mais sont fait
des propositions allez vous voter pour
au parlement c'est sur un parlement la
bonne idée peut venir de n'importe qui
réponse monsieur trudeau avant de passer
à l'autre trio on a créé un système avec
ses 69 qui elle permet d'avoir de
l'approbation ce pour les bons projets
et les mauvais projets n'avanceront pas
bien bon projet pour un poste pourriez
brial imposé écoutez c'est mieux que 2-2
du plus de pétrole sur rails
monsieur deuxième confrontation à trois
messieurs singh bernier et chier on va
poursuivre sur cette histoire de
pipelines qui a fait beaucoup jaser dans
cette campagne électorale le
gouvernement legault répète qu'il n'ya
pas donc au québec d'acceptabilité
sociale monsieur bernier chez vous est
favorable à pipeline si vous étiez de
sylla conscient qu'un ami canadienne qui
me donne le droit
ne craignez-vous pas un ressac un
sentiment anti canada au québec où un
sentiment anti québec dans l'ouest si
vous aller de l'avant nous imposer un
pipeline mais ce chiffre mais c'est la
raison pour laquelle que j'ai proposé
mon corridor énergétique parce que je
sais que les québécois et les
québécoises préfère l'énergie de chez
nous à ce moment beaucoup d'argent des
consommateurs québécois vont aux états
unis vont acheter le pétrole des états
unis ya aucune bon sens je veux créer
une crise les conditions où le lecteur
pour partager son idole et les
ressources naturelles groupe pourrait
être renvoyé de l'ouest canada dans les
marchés laisse ses meilleurs pour les
québécois et québécoises et pour tous
les canadiens
le corridor énergétique que monsieur
chaire propos ça va prendre des années
avant de construire et l'urgence est
d'avoir un oléoduc et vous avez raison
de dire en ce concerne la conscience et
la paix conditionnelle
une tête du pays c'est pour ça les gens
en alberta demande effectivement qu'on
puisse exporter leur pétrole dans le dos
un autre marché que le marché américain
et avec monsieur scheer je pense certain
qu'il va utiliser la constitution pour
s'assurer qu'on soit capable de
construire des pipelines
mais le plus important c'est que
monsieur scheer et monsieur trudeau ont
la même position à ce qui concerne les
changements climatiques
la seule différence est que monsieur
scheer vont imposer des tarifs élevés
aux gros émetteurs il s'agit dans ce que
je vends aussi investi à l'énergie
fossile nous ont dit on veut laisser
sort provinces le québec fait bien pour
les changements climatiques
on devrait laisser sa province et
s'occuper des vrais des vraies actions
pour l'environnement je pense que je
peux résumer la situation aussi pour les
spectateurs
ici ces messieurs publie ici mais ces
messieurs pipeline encore et monsieur
trudeau je pense aussi ces messieurs
pipeline moi je suis jack médecin si je
vais jamais imposé un pipeline sur le
québec ciq l'avait interpellé monsieur
monsieur philippe son actuel de monsieur
trudeau c'était de donner les grands
exemption de prod et sans taxe carbone
pour les grands pollueurs les grandes
compagnies qui a négocié à l'entente
spécial mais les contribuables les
travailleurs canadiens doit p 100 % des
taxes au cra bon j'ai aucune taxe
notamment parmi vous en au sujet des
tarifs élevés maxime et à une subvention
en plus acquis une dimension tu ne va
rien y poser tout ne va même pas gagner
en bourse ok maintenant les gens que les
canadiennes feront taper la taxe et vous
avez l'occasion dans les technologies
nous avons 30 lâche la lutte contre le
changement climatique dans un contexte
global ça c'est la chose qui manque tant
tous les plaignants répondait pour la
jeune votre coeur d'or jean louis
georges un contexte global c'est ça
monsieur chez veut prendre l'argent des
canadiens pour faire contre l'échangé
d'informations compte lutter contre les
changements climatiques dans d'autres
pays et donner encore des millions ou
des milliards de dollars pour lutter
contre les changements climatiques
ailleurs le plus important c'est de
s'assurer que l'environnement ici au
canada soient protégés et aujourd'hui on
encore 215 milliards de l'est
dont usées qui sont déversés dans nos
rivières dans nos lacs dans nos océans
c'est une augmentation de 10% par
rapport à 2013
il faut corriger ça et investir ici pour
les canaliser pour le jeu c'est non pas
les messieurs c'est monsieur singh on a
eu cinq cent mille enfants des de la
jeunesse dans les roues à marianne les
jeunes disent il faut agir de maintenant
on a mis sur trudeau qui est oui un
grand parleur un grand parleur mais en
fait c'est un p tit father et ne marche
pas pour les gens il ne travaille pour
le prodige en ce qu'il faut dès
maintenant c'est de donner aux jeunes
décident espoir on peut dire que oui on
peut aller de l'avant ont annulé les
subventions pétrolière réinvestir dans
l'énergie propre
on peut massivement investi dans l'ain
dans les transports en commun on peut
agir dès maintenant et il faut agir dès
maintenant
et monsieur bernier et messieurs chers
j'ai une question pour vous pour
relancer le débat
vous voulez annulé la taxe carbone est
ce que ce n'est pas donner un permis de
polluer
avis aux entreprises g berne ira en
ciment pas écouté actuellement j'en ai
pas de taxe sur le carbone pour le
québec
donc effectivement donc on veut laisser
les provinces l'environnement c'est une
une compétence partagée avec le fédéral
et les provinces et nous ne le plan ce
qu'ont dit les provinces peuvent
s'occuper des changements climatiques et
nous au fédéral on va continuer à
dépolluer une relaxe nos rivières c'est
important c'est incroyable qu'en 2019 on
a encore des zones qui sont usés qui
sont jetés déjà ville de montréal fait
ça et là c'est maintenant la ville de
vancouver et on veut avoir un
environnement plus propre mais il serait
bien moins chier mais sous celle sur la
taxe carbone sur la taxe carbone est
clair qu'avec messi trouve avec le plan
actuel de légumes en libéral il a donné
une grande exemption au les grands pros
loire alors candidat mais une prise le
croit bon c'est pas pour les grands prix
là c'est seulement pour les gens
ordinaires l'église les travailleurs et
ça c'est le problème avec ce
rapprochement la presse je vais mettre
une concentration sur les technologies
par les taxes le problème avec messieurs
c'est votre plane était écrit par et
pour le secteur perd ce n'est pas
acceptable
ça c'est fait merci messieurs ça met fin
ce 2
m trio je vous félicite rapidement pour
votre discipline
jusqu'ici ça va bien françois cardinal
éditorialiste à la presse bonsoir
françois patrice vos questions au chef
madame et je commence avec vous vous
voulez réduire les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre de manière drastique au
pays pour éviter le pays où l'avait dit
tout à l'heure je vous pose la question
directement
est ce que vous êtes favorable à la
décroissance de l'économie canadienne
même si certains soutiennent que ça
pourrait provoquer beaucoup de pertes
d'emplois merci messieurs c'est une
question extrêmement pertinents
non mais c'est pas en faveur des cross
de croissance de comique adam mais pour
la transformation économique canadien
parce que nous avons besoin c'est vrai
que nous avons besoin comme mais je suis
heureux dit pour la structure nationale
accorde aux mais pas pour les oléoducs
seulement pour l'électricité des
cranberries et avec un grand croissance
de notre capacité dans les renouvelables
énergies renouvelables devant de soleil
mais non avec le prix de soleil qui
allait tomber
énormément nous avons les opportunités
économiques sans étoile merci madame mes
prochaines questions pour monsieur
blanchet une coupe question pour vous
aussi vous dit très fier de votre
plateforme environnementale vous avez
parlé de la péréquation vers tout
honneur comment vous expliquez votre
haie puis au troisième lien entre québec
et lévis d'abord je n'ai pas appuyer le
troisième y est j'ai dit que j'étais pas
contre et j'ai dit que le dépôt pour
pour une raison fort simple
d'abord le ministre de l'environnement
vient de commander un bape
moi j'ai déjà été mises de
l'environnement au québec je respecte le
battre alors si on demande à une
institution dont nous on veut proposer
par loi qu'elle ait préséance sur les
évaluations environnementales du fédéral
sûrement des institutions de faire une
analyse environnementale du projet on va
attendre l'analyse environnementale du
projet et ultime ans le troisième les
exclusivement du gouvernement du québec
et non pas du fédéral
c'est ingérences répétées fini par être
très irritantes
je suis convaincu que québec pourra
prendre les bonnes décisions après le
bas merci monsieur blanchet monsieur
chez vous
être pour la lutte contre les
changements climatiques mais vous
obtenez toujours est précisé que cette à
condition qu'elle se fasse à l'échelle
mondiale est une autre façon commandes
de demander aux autres pays de faire des
efforts pendant que le canada lui
continue de polluer comme si de rien
n'était pas du tout avec mon plan nous
avons une approche équilibrée
nous avons là beaucoup des mesures pour
réduire nos émissions
par exemple avec l'investissement dans
la technologie un crédit d'impôt à pour
les compressions qui adoptent les
nouveaux façon de les méthodes de
production mais on doit reconnaître le
fait que le canada ait mis seulement 1,6
pour cent des émissions et gratter si on
cherche tous les investissements tous
les emplois rendre la vie plus en plus
cher pour tous les canadiens
et on voit l'économie de la chine de
l'inde remplacer tous nos émissions on
peut enfin on accomplit rien et c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons une
approche mondiale
merci monsieur scheer monsieur singh
l'an dernier en début d'année vous
n'étiez pas contre l'expansion du
pipeline trans newton puis vous avez
finalement décidé de vie opposés au fil
de l'année
comment comprendre vos contorsions et
volte-face sur les projets de transport
de gaz et pétrole dont cas pour moi
c'est clair la future de notre pays de
futur de notre planète c'est un futur où
on n'utilise pas hockin énergies
fossiles ça c'est l'avenir
est ce que je veux faire pour les
enfants qui s'inquiètent de l'avenir
pour les familles qui ont font face des
inondations pour les gens qui me disent
qu'ils ont peur des feux de forêt je
veux dire je vais mettre tous mes
efforts pour s'attaquer à la crise
climatique il faut le faire on peut le
faire et pour moi c'est un engagement
forte
merci monsieur singh monsieur trudeau
vous avez premier en 2015 de mettre fin
aux subventions à l'industrie pétrolière
et pourtant vous avez non seulement
acheter un pipeline pendant votre mandat
on en a parlé tout à l'heure mais vous
avez aussi offert un programme d'un de
plus de 1 milliard de dollars à
l'industrie pétrolière comment
aujourd'hui peut-on croire vos promesses
environnementales
on est encore en train de bataille nos
cibles d'éliminer les subventions à
l'industrie pétrolière jusqu'en 2025
ça prend une progression aussi que la
transition ne peut pas se faire du jour
au lendemain c'est pour ça qu'on est en
train d'investir de la bonne façon dans
l'énergie verte dans l'énergie
renouvelable et tous les profits des
centaines de millions de dollars de cet
oléoduc vont aller vers cette transition
vers la lutte contre les changements
climatiques
on a un vrai plan parce qu'on le livret
pendant quatre ans il faut continuer
faut avoir un gouvernement fort plein de
québécois plein de francophones qui vont
pouvoir continuer de tenir tête comptait
ses conservateurs qui veulent rien faire
merci monsieur trudeau dernière question
pour vous monsieur bernier vous êtes le
seul chef à refuser le consensus
scientifique sur l'urgence climatique en
citant toujours la même poignée de
détracteurs plutôt controversé monsieur
bernier pourquoi renier vous la science
premièrement je ne renie pas la science
et deuxièmement pour bien dire que 500
scientifiques à travers le monde qui ont
écrit au secrétaire général de l'onu
pour dire qu'il n'y avait pas d'urgence
climatique donc je ne suis pas le seul
il faut bâtir des politiques publiques
non pas sur des sentiments et un urgence
qui est une urgence qui n'existe pas
mais sur l'effet sur la raison et ce
qu'on demande qui est encore plus des
études sur l'impact du soleil par
rapport aux changements climatiques
les études qu'ils ont eue actuellement
était seulement sur l'impact co2 et si
vous voulez vraiment atteindre les
cibles
elisabeth à la raison elle a des cibles
qui vont faire intentions qu'on va
atteindre les cibles de paris mais elle
va détruire l'économie comme vous l'avez
dit plus tôt c'est la seule chef qui est
crédible tout en détruisant l'économie
merci monsieur bernier merci merci
françois merci beaucoup
alors on est déjà
à notre deuxième thème économie et
finances publiques et nous avons dans la
salle une citoyenne marie saint jean qui
veut poser une question chef madame
saint-jean bonsoir à vous pensez merci à
vous merci d'être là votre question il
vous écoute en voici lorsqu'on est âgé
et à la retraite
il en coûte beaucoup plus cher de vivre
ce cas deux avaient tout ça et on peut
pas bénéficier entre autres du partage
des revenus qu'on est seul pour absorber
toutes les dépenses alors prévoyez vous
augmentez les pensions des retraités ou
encore majoré la déduction en raison de
l'âge en d'autres mots quelles mesures
fiscales
prévoyez vous pour aider les personnes
âgées vivant seules
très bonne question très clair merci
beaucoup madame saint jean monsieur
blanchet vous répondez en premier
bonjour dame saint jean le premier ce
que vous mettez en place et lit
remarquable d'abord parce que il ya une
forte qu à qu'on appelle les baby boomer
qui vont arriver à la retraite une
retraite qu'il mérite heureuse qu'il
mérite passablement prospère parce
qu'ils ont construit la société dans
laquelle on vit où on propose une
augmentation de 110 dollars par mois de
la pension des yes emportant plusieurs
crédits d'impôt sur les activités
physiques un congé il de ou une
prolongation du versement pour le
conjoint lors du décès du conjoint la
protection des fonds de pension comme
créancier prioritaire lors d'une
faillite ou de l'association des
activités d'une entreprise un ensemble
de mesures que je vous invite à
consulter dans le détail on répondra à
vos questions
parce que on pense que c'est important
de dire si les jours merci monsieur
blanchet monsieur c'est clair que là
coût de la vie est un autre enjeu très
important dans ce grand pays
c'est le thème central de notre
plateforme on va rendre la vie plus
abordable pour tous les canadiens qui
viennent pour les québécois et
québécoises spécifiquement pour les
personnages et les gens qui à prendre
qui a pris leur retraite on va augmenter
le crédit en raison d'âge par mille
dollars
aussi à beaucoup de nos crédits d'impôt
va appliquer à
allez là les personnes âgées comme le
crédit d'impôt pour le transport en
commun et aussi on va éliminer la tps
pour les factures dossier et pour les
personnes avec une crème fixer les
revenus fixes et ça c'est important
merci monsieur cher monsieur trudeau
merci même et saint jean pour votre
question la première une des premières
choses que nous avons fait c'est
d'augmenter le supplément de revenu
garanti pour nos aînés les plus
vulnérables souvent des femmes seules
mais on sait qu'il ya encore plus à
faire c'est pour ça qu'on a promis de
bonifier la sécurité de la vieillesse
à partir de l'âge de 75 ans de 10%
ici il ya une personne âgée qui perd son
conjoint
c'est un moment extrêmement difficile et
c'est pour ça qu'on va augmenter les
pensions de survivants des régime des
rentes de jusqu'à 75% de ce qu'ils
recevaient avant parce qu'on sait que
d'appuyer nos aînés c'est essentiel dans
une société riche généreuse comme
l'anneau merci monsieur trudeau madame
mail votre réponse merci mesdames un
sens jacques je veux ajouter parce que
j'ai oublié un commencement que je
reconnaître que nous sommes ici des
peuples autochtones non c'était un
coquin jeudi mais gouache
non je veux dire que oui le parti vert
sont vraiment engagés pour augmenter le
niveau de pension pour aider les ag où
un même j'ai 65 ans alors je suis
absolument dont le même position peut
pas mais je ne sais pas en plâtre et de
retraite immédiatement alors je veux
faire aussi mettre sur pied une
stratégie pour les années et aussi
mettre le pied dans le cabinet d'un
ministre avec le but de protéger
merci madame et monsieur bernier
mais on vient de s'apercevoir que tous
les autres chefs ici pour remettre vous
promettre que vous ce que vous voulez
entendre et donc faire en sorte qu'on va
augmenter les pensions pour les aînés
moi je vous dis la vérité sa vérité
c'est que le pays est endetté
on n'a pas les moyens et la seule
promesse que je vous fais c'est
d'équilibrer le budget en deux ans et
après ça seulement après ça on va
regarder pour baisser les taxes et les
impôts mais les gens ici il n'y a pas de
limite
pas de déficit et c'est comme si rien
n'était et pour les programmes sociaux
pour les programmes canadiens c'est
important d'équilibrer notre budget tout
de suite parce que si jamais une
récession dans quelques années on n'aura
plus de marge de manoeuvre
donc je ne sais pas d'acheter votre vote
avec votre argent je vous dis merci a
hérité merci monsieur même je saigne
terminée oui mais si madame pour la
question avez vous avez soulevé un enjeu
qui touche beaucoup de monde
merci pour prendre le temps pour
expliquer ça je pense que c'est
tellement tellement ridicule que les
personnes âgées font face les grands
défis comme ça les gens qui on sacrifie
si beaucoup ils ont le droit d'avoir
leur retraite avec la dignité ce qu'on
va faire c'est de mettre en oeuvre des
programmes pour vous aider oui il faut
augmenter les pensions
aussi il veut il faut augmenter les
services comme la science médicament
universel qui va sauver centaines de la
doller le soin dentaire nationale qui va
aussi réduire les coûts et sauver
d'argent ou si on veut mettre en oeuvre
une limite sur les fesses c'est lui là
savent aussi sur et argent merci à vous
merci monsieur c est ce que vous êtes un
peu plus éclairées quant à votre vote je
vous demande pas pour qui bien sûr mais
tous les programmes sont intéressants
alors on verra dans quatre à merci merci
beaucoup pour votre stationnaire
merci alors premier trio économique avec
monsieur saint mamet et monsieur
blanchet aucun de vous trois ne proposer
des baisses d'impôts au contraire vous
promettez vous venez d'en parler mais se
sont rapidement de nouvelles taxes de
nouveaux programmes coûteux
vous ne pensez pas que la classe moyenne
a besoin d'un répit je commence avec
vous monsieur c je pense que les classes
moyennes a besoin des aides
donc on va jamais augmenter les taxes
sur les classes moyennes où les
travailleurs et travailleuses mais là
problème c'est les plus riches et nappez
parle juste par les plus riches ont
beaucoup d'argent et ne le partage pas
donc ce qu'on veut faire pas des belles
paroles et pas des actions comme sur
trudeau mais on va mettre en place une
taxe sur les riches ça va donner une
augmentation de revenus de 77 milliards
de dollars donc on peut trouver l'argent
si on veut investir dans les
on les vues les autres gouvernement qui
investit dans les grands combats ni avec
des milliards de dollars moi je vais
investir dans les gens parce que je ne
travaille pas plus riches
je travaille pour vous les riches et
notre programme et nous avons le seul
programme dans ces élections
chifflet nous avons un prat forme
chiffrée nous avons les preuves de
chercher les revenus chrome dont quand
monsieur singh aussi dit que sur les
taxes sur les plus riches mais aussi
pour est actionné les web gillon comme
facebook qui n'est flex et chercher les
fonds parce que on doit mettre sur pied
plus pour les citoyens du canada éliminé
les frais de scolarité investissez dont
l'éducation postsecondaire et aussi nous
sommes absolument engager pour un
programme de l'assurance médicaments
mais en même temps pour la livraison
postale à domicile tous les choses sont
possibles son possible pour aider les ag
mais on doit choisir les premiers
recueils et trouver leur est venue pour
équilibrer le budget en cinq ans jette
sur la glace à vous de jouer ce bétail
inexactes fois à part monsieur scheer et
monsieur 5 tout le monde a déposé je
crois des plateformes financières
déposer des cadres financiers qu'ils
respectent les règles en notant que je
suis concernée est d'accord sur le
principe qu'il faut aller chercher
davantage de revenus qu'il faut pas que
ces revenus là viennent toujours des
mêmes poches
or il est exact qu'il y a des paradis
fiscaux de l'évasion fiscale qui
favorise toujours les mêmes
il est exact qu'on peut faire en sorte
avec les géants du web avec une
redevance de 3% dont je pense par contre
qui doit être réservé l'argent c'est
beaucoup d'argent dans les centaines de
millions de dollars réservé au secteur
culturel et des médias qui en ont bien
besoin
donc je pense qu'il faut travailler dans
ce sens mais je pense qu'on peut
regarder les revenus de la péréquation
verte qui vont baisser les dépenses du
fédéral parce que ça va venir des
provinces plus riches et je pense qu'on
peut regarder les 400 millions de
dollars d'une déclaration d'impôt unique
qui seraient sauvées aux contribuables
aux entreprises et à l'état demande
unanime de l'assemblée nationale du
québec demandent que le bloc portera
bien sûr
on enlève éventuellement des
conservateurs qui disaient d'accord avec
ça et monsieur 5e le disque était
d'accord s'il n'y avait pas de pertes
d'emplois
si je pense que là dessus on est tous
d'accord il n'y aurait pas de perdants
pour ça donc voici 400 millions de
dollars oui je vais aussi ajouté un
autre point
c'est une question de revenus mais c'est
aussi une question de choix donc dans le
derrière nez à nez ce que mr triaud a
fait dépenser beaucoup de donneurs
qu'être 14 milliards de dollars pour les
plus riches aux entreprises pour
qu'elles puissent acheter des avions
d'éléments dans l'économie de l'automne
jusque sahel à 10 85 milliards de
dollars pour acheter un pipeline et pour
les prêts pour les grands compagnie des
grandes entreprises il a dit il va
annuler 6 milliards de dettes pour les
complications de grandes compagnies en
général pour moi ça c'est 20 5 millions
de dollars qu'elle a donnée et plus
riches au lieu des derniers très bien
aux messes commencé pour reçu un second
mandat mais ce qu'on a beaucoup reçu
comme courriel comme questions du public
c'est l'inquiétude vis-à-vis cette dette
qui grandit et du difficile alors on a
un mot là vous trois est-ce que ça vous
inquiète tout ça vous inquiète paul
difficiles à tuer le déficit bien kg est
parce que le gouvernement libéral a fait
pour donner des milliards de dollars aux
plus riches
si on prend des actions pour investir
dans les gens au journal as mais avec la
troupe plateforme chez frais
le bourget sera équilibré en cinq ans
sont un événement comme en récession
mais en même temps je vais ajouter que
les subventions der l'énergie fossile
ont augmenté depuis la dernière
qu'attend aller chercher l'argent dans
les poches des riches est une chose
faire en sorte que ça et au bon endroit
est une chose
ben c'est le déficit en ethno simon peut
pas du jour au lendemain
dire on va couper un déficit de 19
milliards parce que l'impact sur
l'économie de l'ensemble du pays et du
québec serait catastrophique
notre plateforme nous sa baisse à peu
près de la moitié difficile je trouve
pas ça merveilleux mais on peut pas
aller plus vite que ça faut vraiment
aller chercher les revenus
supplémentaires faut vraiment faire en
sorte que sans aller chercher de
l'argent dans les poches des
contribuables
les entreprises les géants du
couper les subventions toutes les formes
dead revente transmanche ne pas investir
dans la réfection de france membres sont
des moyens d'aller chercher beaucoup
d'argent merci à vous trois deuxième
trio sur l'économie monsieur bernier
monsieur trudeau et monsieur chien
monsieur trudeau vous n'avez pas de plat
aucun plan de retour à l'équilibré
budgétaire monsieur bernier vous voulez
coupé allègrement vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure mais souchier on n'a toujours
pas vos chiffres vous donnez votre cadre
financier comment on peut savoir où vous
allez coupé alors premièrement j'ai fait
une haie engagement très clair on va
équilibrer le budget en cinq ans et
toutes nos annonces étaient tout chiffré
par le directeur parlementaire du budget
c'est au contraire de monsieur trudeau
qui a présenté une plateforme écrit sur
napkin au coin de table parce que aucune
après plus de cinq ans portant de saison
de quoi entrer le chiffre pourquoi on a
préféré un ver activités auxquelles on a
représenté un quart ou son échec complet
chiffré à prouver à 2,56 à le dire car
le mans terre du budget mais la réalité
c'est qu'on avait tellement d'ambition
pour les investissements les baisses
d'impôts pour la classe moyenne mais
j'en ai chié on n'a pas baissé les
impôts des plus riches
vous promettez une baisse d'impôt de 50
mille dollars celui-ci millionnaire si
vous avez une baisse d'impôts et jack
celle qui est plus les familles qui font
non je suis juste d'années que finissez
votre idée après monsieur berniche
social mensonge vous avez menti quand
les premières à sortir l'histoire vous
avez menti quand vous avez dit que
j'aurais jamais pensé écrit cherchiez
vous manquez de la classe moyenne
on dit qu'il est on les a augmentées
pour les plus riches
j'ai très bien commencé mais ce sera un
à la fois jusqu'à la fin monsieur
cheverny
mais je regarde ici
les chefs des partis si vous disent tout
qu'ils vont équilibrer le budget en cinq
ans et vous demande un mandat de quatre
ans donc personne va équilibrer le
budget monsieur scheer va additionner 70
milliards de dollars sur la dette
monsieur trudeau à faire la même chose
c'est irresponsable
les finances publiques on ne peut plus
additionner la carte de crédit
nationales et les plaines et pour faire
en sorte la seule promesse que chez vous
l'avez dit c'est des coupures on peut
couper les subventions aux entreprises
monsieur chirac continue à donner des
subventions aux entreprises son trou
d'eau ici et si on veut relancer
l'économie faut remettre de l'argent
n'avait pas les entrepreneurs les
entrepreneurs beaucerons en beauce et
entrepreneurs de partout les et nous on
va le faire parce qu'on va trouver bien
je vous remercie monsieur b document
conservatoire on l'entend du bien
souvent on l'a vu pendant dix ans sous
monsieur europe et où vous étiez tous
les deux à faisait partie de ce parti on
a vu des coûts peut on a vu des baisses
d'impôts pour les mieux nantis on a vu
des sous-investissements dans
l'infrastructure dans les personnes
âgées dans nos jeunes et sa pole livrer
une croissance économique depuis quatre
ans des investissements dans la classe
moyenne
on s'est vus millions d'emplois créés
sont les plus bas taux de chômage de
libye et aux 900 mille personnes au
sujet de sujets trop des mensonges dans
cette discours que j'attends de répondre
les légions de leurs revenus faibles à
bonifier le plus de notre plan
économique
et c'est l'excusé pour les grands
déficits de judith société pour dépenser
l'argent dans les futures et là
directeur par le budget alimentaire a
dit qu' à aucun plan alors en le pire de
l'est du moral des grands déficits et
aucune projet d'edf d'un futur et la
cour la cour de ses déficits augmentent
et augmentent le plus plus en plus
d'argent des contribuables doit à
l'épopée l'intérêt de la société
l'investissement en infrastructures les
gens peuvent aller voir dans leurs
villes dans leur communauté les échanges
50 logement social les investissements
qu'on a choisi de faire parce que les
conservateurs sous monsieur harper nous
ont sous investi et nous on a fait le
choix d'écrire de façon raisonnable dans
notre avenir et vous avez créé un
déficit et vous avez créé actuellement
l'intérêt sur la dette seulement ces 26
milliards de dollars par année
y a plus une marge de manoeuvre c'est
irresponsable et actuellement plusieurs
économistes disent monsieur trudeau
qu'on risque de s'en aller vers une
récession dans quelques années ici c'est
le cas ça va être désastreux pour les
programmes sociaux il faut avoir une
politique responsable et ce n'est pas en
dépensant l'argent du gouvernement que
vous créer la richesse c'est vous le cul
de l'agencé font fuir les
investissements dans les gens dans les
travailleurs dans les familles sakri la
résilience dans les familles dans les
communautés c'est pas de garder un
groupe ou d'argent pour quand on en a
besoin et viser que de lui donner les
investissements aux gens pour te faire
de la résilience c'est ça qui va nous
créer des opportunités saisies temps
difficiles on le comprend mais se
suiciderait coupure nous sur le dos
justin trudeau a rebondi le chiffre
monsieur chirurgie commencez à vous
poser une question a raconté la lutte
fiscale pour tous les cas il a augmenté
les impôts pour 80 % des familles de la
classe moyenne
nous avons proposé un plan d' équilibré
le bouger danser on ne pourront même
envie et je vous sens du temps de l'an
où s'en vont j'ai pas le droit
d'apparaître moins à 100 mais je
démontre bien sourit de cinq ans nous
avons également dafoe aucune lettre
parce que vous prenez
merci merci merci merci fin de blog
c'est normal ça s'échauffe sénégal
pensez aux gens la maison pensez aux
gens à la maison à qui vous voulez
envoyer vos messages
en même temps ça passe plus et leur
budget ti du devoir dont soir soir
patrice question on cherche surtout à
autre chose ce thème d'icônes messieurs
si on commence avec vous d'abord très
rapidement parce que plusieurs citoyens
nous ont écrit à ce sujet allez-vous
changer l'âge de la retraite qui est à
60,50 non bon alors on n'a toujours pas
votre cadre financier mais vous voulez
rééquilibrer le budget en cinq ans
le précédent gouvernement conservateur a
découpé dans la culture et la recherche
scientifique vous est ce que vous allez
faire la même chose pour éliminer le
déficit
alors nous avons déjà annoncé les
endroits où on va trouver les épargnants
pour les canadiens qui on va protéger la
clôture à va protéger les
investissements dans les technologies et
de la région on va éliminer 2 5
milliards de dollars pour les
subventions coopératif et on va couper
l'aide étrangère par 20 5% on va on va
rester hors va garder cet argent ici
chez nous
lorsqu'on peut rendre la vie plus
abordable on va baisser les impôts on va
réintroduire les crédits d'impôt pour
les activités ce n'est pas de cooper
ancien de ça et le racisme haïr est
d'accord la prochaine question et pour
monsieur bernier monsieur bernier vous
avez promis d'abolir la gestion de
l'offre en agriculture
alors qu'on parle de plus en plus
d'acheter et de manger local qu'est ce
que vous dites aux conseils aux
consommateurs qui craignent de voir
leurs tablettes d'épicerie inondé par du
lait et du poulet produit aux états unis
par exemple
premièrement ils vont voir liberté de
choix et les produits qui vont devoir
venir au canada vont devoir respecter
les normes sanitaires canadiennes c'est
très important
mais le plus important c'est que chaque
famille canadienne va sauver 400 dollars
et sonné par année si on est sérieux on
veut faut abolir ce système là qu est un
système socialiste un cartel mais le
plus important monsieur scheer viennent
dire tout à l'heure qui vacille et
d'écrivains budget en faisant des
coupures c'est facile d'équilibrer le
budget il s'agit de couper l'aide
internationale on peut économiser cinq
milliards là il faut rapatrier cet
argent là ici au canada prédit les
candidats bas il une des choses qu'on
peut faire pour aider les plus démunis
c'est effectivement abolir ce cartel ce
cartel de la gestion de l'offre les
familles canadiennes vont économiser
madame mais votre cadre financier a été
démoli par ce que vous proposez
d'ajouter soixante dix milliards de
dépenses dès la première année
comment allez vous convaincre les
électeurs que vous êtes crédibles en
matière de finances publiques parce que
notre plateforme chiffre est étudié par
l'institut spéciale pour la démarque
aussi avec notre invention directeur du
bureau parlementaire de bouger monsieur
kevin pêche et il est donné le budget un
bon note ouais ouais c'est la passe il
adorait aller oui mais c'est vrai que
nous sommes le seul où et avec un tout
programme compréhensif est chiffré leur
a hérité c'est que on doit faire plus
nous sommes un pays riche
on doit augmenter notre système pour
justice sociale on doit faire plus pour
le soin des enfants pour les garderies
pour les personnes âgées elle fait
vraiment possible c'est tout à condat
merci monsieur trudeau en 2015 vous
proposiez des déficits pour investir
dans les infrastructures et les
électeurs vous ont suivi en 2019 vous
proposer encore de vivre à crédit
d'alourdir la dette de 100 milliards
mais maintenant c'est pour des dépenses
courantes
si jamais il ya une récession quelle
marge de manoeuvre
aurez-vous nous on croit que l'important
c'est de pouvoir aider nos jeunes à
trouver de bons emplois à voir
l'éducation nécessaire à aider les
familles à pouvoir offrir les
opportunités à leurs enfants pour qu'ils
puissent grandir en sécurité avec toutes
les opportunités qui pourraient avoir
ces investissements ç'a fonctionné
pendant quatre ans on a vu neuf cent
mille personnes sorties de l'ecir
récession monsieur trudeau c est ce que
vous aurez les marges de manoeuvres où
on va les obliger à boire des déficits
deux fois trois fois plus élevé oui on
va voir la marge de manoeuvre parce que
notre plan a été coté triple à par les
les
agences de crédit à l'international il
ya juste l'allemagne et le canada qui a
qui ont un crédit unanime de premier
plan parce que notre plan est
responsable et raisonnable de sur le
cadre fiscal
merci monsieur singh comme monsieur
chère vous avez ça en partage vous
n'avez toujours pas votre cadre
financier mais on sait que vous
promettez des programmes très coûteux
par exemple l'assurance médicaments à
l'assurance dentaire
vous êtes toujours que vous allez faire
payer les riches mais les experts nous
disent qu'on surestime toujours l'argent
qu'on peut aller chercher de ce côté là
c'est connu les red lions des bons
fiscaliste alors comment allez-vous
dissiper l'impression que votre pain
relève un peu de la pensée magique
donc ce qu'on va faire c'est un on pense
que c'est important de la faire donc oui
c'est difficile de faire les bonnes
choses mais on a la crosse de le faire
quand même
ah mais aussi on a choisi des chiffres
tellement spécifique parce qu'on sait
avec la taxe le autriche
on a dit pour les gens qui ont plus de
20 millions $ on va mettre un texte 1%
parce que on a évalué qu avec un pur
sang c'est plus difficile pour échapper
l'argent que dans le pays
donc on n'était pas respecté ça mais en
général on sait que si on augmente les
financements pour l'heure est venue de
s'assurer qu'on a c'est révolu on peut
le faire avec les financements des
employés qui cherchent l'argent dont
notre gouvernement peut le faire merci
monsieur blanchet enfin vous êtes
content les pipelines
mais vous ne dénoncez toujours pas le
gazoduc gnl québec qui se rendra jusqu'à
saguenay dit nous est ce que vous vous
opposez aux hydrocarbures seulement
quand c'est l'alberta qui empochent les
profits a fait en toute cohérence et
j'ai déjà répondu un peu à son un peu
plus tôt garin bureau d'audiences
publiques en environnement sur le projet
de gnl
j'étais assez clair sur le fait que je
pense que les hydrocarbures
puis les énergies fossiles sont les
énergies du passé qui a pas d'avenir
lada c'est pas par là qu'il faut aller
c'est pas ces projets là qu'il faut
réaliser mais en toute cohérence comme
ancien ministre de l'environnement
j'attends le rapport du bape
puis je m'attends pas à ce que le bape
soit favorable à gnl je vais attendre
on va même déposé un projet de loi pour
que le bape ait préséance sur les
institutions fédéral d'évaluation
environnementale alors par souci de
cohérence
on va attendre le bac le bas vont
arriver on va prendre une position sur
cet enjeu
je m'attends à ce que le bape soit
passablement sévère merci merci beaucoup
hélène pour vos questions si la fin de
ce deuxième thème prochain thème
[Musique]
services aux citoyens nous avons pour
débuter ce thème un citoyen à toronto à
mississauga très exactement marque
gravel monsieur gravel
les chefs vous écoute vous voulez parler
des services en français pour les
minorités francophones hors québec on
vous écoute
bonsoir madame messieurs vivre dans une
minorité est un défi avec les récentes
coupes provinciale c'est devenu encore
plus difficile sur le plan fédéral s'est
pas obtenu non plus parce que l'un
services sont difficiles à avoir par
exemple demander à un préposé au bureau
des passeports de le rencontrer vous
venez de multiplier par dix votre temps
d'attentes
air canada avoir un agent de bord ou un
préposé qui parlent français de toronto
relève presque du miracle
malgré les plaintes les nombreuses
plaintes auprès du commissaire des
changes ne change pas ma question est la
suivante comment
et concrètement et quels outils
d'intérêt vous le commissaire aux
langues officielles pour qu'il puisse
enfin faire respecter cette loi est
donné à tous les francophones du canada
un service adéquat est équivalent aux
autres très clair comme question
monsieur vous êtes le premier à répondre
alors merci beaucoup pour la question
c'est l'enjeu est très important c'est
peut-être ça va être une surprise mais
le français c'est pas ma première langue
et je suis natif de toi et c'est grâce
une décision de mes parents anglophones
que j'ai appris le français en est une
école et mesure et je fais des grands
efforts j'apprends mon subjonctif malgré
les parfums de mes paroles j'ai toujours
essayé d'armures et marc français
concrètement j'ai eu une réunion j'ai
organisé une réunion entre tous les
chefs de pratique fédéral pour régler le
problème avec
l'université francophone je vais appuyer
j'ai fait un engagement très clair après
cette université et j'ai proposé de
moderniser à la loi sur les langues
officielles
merci madame et oui merci monsieur le
gr20 c'est une question très importante
parce que c'est trop longtemps que nous
n'avons pas moderniser la loi sur les
langues officielles
on doit le faire et dont le fassions
crois pas ce que vous avez demandé les
réponses concrètes les choses que je
pense que c'est extrêmement beau temps
c'est de donner vire le commissaire de
l'unc officiel le pouvoir de punir plus
de pouvoirs pour exiger que tous les
argents ce haut dans le domaine fédéral
présenté les services à 10 k et était
égale pour les deux langues officielles
dont les premières années de mon mandat
merci madame et monsieur bernier oui
merci la question c'est très important
le fédéral devrait réinvestir dans ses
champs de compétence et c'est ce qu'on
va faire pour les langues officielles et
pour les autres services que le
gouvernement fédéral offre aux citoyens
vous avez ici des gens autour de vous
des leaders de partis qui vous disent
qu'ils vont investir dans le logement
social dans la santé dans l'éducation
ce sont des champs de juridiction
provinciale et nous notre politique
c'est de respecter la convention
canadienne ne pas s'ingérer dans les
champs de compétence provinciale est de
redonner les ressources au gouvernement
fédéral pour s'assurer de donner les
bons services en français aux
francophones à l'extérieur du québec et
en anglais aux anglophones mais aussi
les autres services que vous avez parlé
tout à l'heure un gouvernement fédéral
formé dans ses champs de merci merci
monsieur bernier monsieur blanchet vous
savez les québécois savent ce qui est
une minorité parce que même si les
francophones du québec si je peux me
permettre de dire comme ça sont
majoritaires au québec on est très très
minoritaire en amérique
je suis allé en ontario il ya des gens
qui ont trouvé ça étrange mais les
francophones hors québec et les acadiens
sont nos frères et nos soeurs
francophone de l'ensemble du continent
et du canada je pense que le commissaire
aux langues officielles pour bien faire
son travail doit ramener la notion de
réciprocité
il faut que les communautés francophones
à l'extérieur du québec et les
communautés acadiennes est le même
niveau de service que les communautés où
la communauté anglophone
historique et précieuse du québec il
faut que les francophones au canada et
les acadiens et le même niveau de
service que les anglais du québec
merci monsieur blanc cher monsieur singh
oui merci merci monsieur gravel peu la
question peut-être comme vous pouvez
entendre réussi un francophone mais je
suis fortement francophile je l'étais
pas chanceuse d'avoir aucune classe
d'immersion français mais abandonne 1
enfance j'ai en fait j'ai tombé en amour
avec la langue française la langue
molière et je veux partager cette
richesse parce que c'était une richesse
dans ma vie dans ce qu'on veut faire
concrètement c'est de moderniser la
langue officielle de mieux financer les
services français parce qu'il faut le
faire
si le gouvernement peut faire quelque
chose de faire quelque chose et le fait
c'est une question du courage cette
question de volonté
on a la volonté parce que c'est
tellement important merci monsieur
cheikh monsieur trudeau merci monsieur
gravel pour votre question vous
souviendrez comme moi longtemps de ce
que monsieur ford a fait 2 qui est venu
au pouvoir de couper dans les services
aux francophones
malgré qu'ils s'étaient dits pour les
gens quand il se fait élire mais c'est
ce que ça que font les conservateurs
nous notre su défendre les minorités
francophones en ontario et à travers le
pays on va continuer de le faire
on a fait un investissement record dans
les communautés francophones ou des
communautés de langue officielle en
situation minoritaire à travers le pays
on s'est engagé à moderniser la loi sur
les langues officielles
on comprend la lutte que vous vivez à
tous les jours et on sera toujours avec
vous merci monsieur trudeau et je
remercie surtout monsieur gravel d'avoir
posé cette question merci j'espère ça
nous a éclairé monsieur gravel
merci premier trio sur ce thème de
services aux citoyens monsieur singh ce
chiffre est monsieur blanchet vous êtes
donc questionner et vous pouvez
interagir bien sûr on a parlé je parle
de la question autochtone on a parlé de
génocide culturel
on a parlé des pensionnats des femmes
disparues de réserve sans logement ou
eau potable alors la question est très
simple à peut pas être plus simple
qu'est ce que vous allez faire
concrètement
pour améliorer la condition de vie des
autochtones messieurs je peux commencer
monsieur moi j'ai porté encore le tout
bon jeu pour éviter cette problème
meilleur et on continue quand même
donc en fait cette question tellement
sérieuse ce que j'ai vu c'est monsieur
trudeau a donné beaucoup des belles
paroles en public mais c'est vraiment ce
qui les décisions qu'il fait en privé
c'est le problème donc avec la
communauté autochtone c'est clair si on
veut agir dès maintenant on peut agir
donc la question c'est ça si on respect
le fait que les enfants autochtones ont
le droit d'avoir les mêmes financements
il ne faut pas les plots suis dans le
cour de justice comme ce trou doit à
fait ce que je fais je vais respecter la
communauté autochtone ça c'est
primordial
c'est le premier étape c'est le respect
et la dignité si on commence avec ça ça
veut dire combien fin et finance le
comité autochtone avec le financement
égale très bien c'est un débat mais ce
cher monsieur blanchet a livré ce sujet
merci beaucoup
une inspectent respecter les premiers
nation c'est de respecter quand les
communautés autochtones dit oui dit oui
au début des projets pour près d la
croissance économique
et quand on parle des communautés dans
les endroits éloignés ou rural les
secteurs qui créent le plus d'emplois
pour les premiers nation c'est le
secteur minière les secteurs forestière
et le secteur énergétique et c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'ai dit que je
vais nommer une ministre avec leurs
responsabilités pour faire les
consultations dans une manière dynamique
pour assurer qu'en respecte nos
obligations comme un mouvement avec les
traités du blanche et les relations avec
les premiers peuples sont marquées par
un déficit de confiance parce que c'est
ma compréhension
c'est la compréhension qu'on doit en
avoir parce que ce sont de véritables
nations avec les mêmes droits privilèges
obligations et responsabilités que des
véritables nations mais il ya une
déclaration de l'onu
des enquêtes des études des commissions
et me disais c'est eux qui disent pour
ce que je suis à l'aise le dis pas ça
doit venir 2
que ça ne vient pas il n'y a pas de
suites concrètes qu'on ne met pas en
oeuvre des démarches clair qu'on fait
tout ce qui était au ritz qui est beau
et puis pendant ce temps là les
solutions ne se trouve pas le respect ne
s'établit pas la confiance ne se
construit pas il va falloir modifier une
relation profonde avec les premiers
peuples en disant que la vie des
populations
c'est pas un mot c'est une réalité
auxquels ils ont droit comme nous non je
suis tellement d'accord avec ce que
monsieur blanchet a dit en fait si on
part de respect j'ai visité prassinos
cette intimité empoisonné par le mercure
mais messieurs trop d'eau dans un v
événement privé elle s'est moquée de
quelqu'un qui est milité pour dire notre
lot est emprisonné qu'est ce que vous
allez faire
elle a dit merci pour votre donné que
c'est complètement incompréhensible
comment quelqu'un peut faire ça si on a
visité cette immunité
on a vu les impacts et l'emprisonnement
sur les corps des gens comment les
enfants et tremblent à cause de cet
empoisonnement
c'est je n'ai pas les mots peut dire
comment être quelqu un peut de dire
c'est bon si les passe quelque chose
très bien très bien je vais je vais
arrêter le chronomètre sur ce trio là
comme vous avez pointé monsieur trudeau
sur une question très précis je vous
donne 20 secondes monsieur trudeau pour
répondre à cette question peut ouvrir la
lumière de monsieur trudeau et les airs
si nous avons fait énormément pour
investir dans les communautés
autochtones à travers le pays nous
travail mais sur ce que j'ai dit que la
communauté de grassy narrows on a
travaillé avec travaille avec eux pour
approuver un centre de traitement et on
va donner le financement nécessaire pour
ce centre de très très bien alors vous
aurez votre votre tour je vais vous
parler de la question autochtone dans
votre trio ont pu refermer la lumière de
monsieur trudeau je vous lance un peu
c'est un peu chacun là on trouve des
milliards de dollars pour acheter les
oléoducs qui on trouve pas l'argent
après des années et des années et des
années pour donner de l'eau potable à
des communautés autochtones n est pas
vraiment de la politique c'est
fondamental
c'est élémentaire un minimum de respect
et de dignité pour des peuples qui sont
autant des peuples que nous s'il vous
plaît s'il faut reconnaître que à peu
près tous les partis pas à peu près tous
les partis se sont succédé et
constate que c'est très difficile de
voir des améliorations concrètes
ce chien c'est une défi mais c'est
essentiel que nous avons un mouvement
qui prend ses responsabilités sérieux ça
c'est mon engagement pour les premiers
nation on va assurer qu'il n'y a pas
seulement des investissements mais un
nouveau système pour assurer que
l'investissement fonction c'est pas
seulement une question d'argent c'est
aussi de rétablir les dynamiques dans
les départements j'ai propre et j'ai
proposé de moderniser ce suédois ou pour
les premiers des nations alors qu'ils
peuvent bénéficier de leurs des
ressources naturelles sur les réserves
et les japs tremplin vous s'élargissent
et les ressources naturelles la clé
c'est par la coordination le créé le
problème clé c'est on a eu des
gouvernements conservateurs et les goûts
nos libéraux qu'ils ont choisi des
négligés les communautés autochtones
c'est ça ils ont eu la chance de la
faire si elle veut faire pour que
quelque chose pour le secteur pétrolier
il saute pour acheter un pipeline est
sûre pour donner des milliards de
subventions c'est surtout s'il vous
plaît faites et les premiers blocs ne
l'imposé pas de papa ottawa ils ont
droit de participer aux choix et aux
décisions très bien sur la fin de ce
trio deuxième confrontation sur ce thème
et nous allons poursuivre sur le thème
des autochtones monsieur trudeau
pourquoi c'est très récent vendredi
dernier vous êtes allé en appel d'un
jugement ordonnant qui vous ordonné au
gouvernement de verser 40 mille dollars
à des enfants autochtones confiait la
protection de l'enfance vous deviez pas
être le champion justement de la
réconciliation oui et on est et on
continue de l'être
on est d'accord avec le tribunal qu'il
faut absolument compenser ses enfants et
on va le faire on va travailler avec eux
pour établir les bons niveaux mais on a
pu à faire des investissements concret
au cours des quatre dernières années on
a levé 87 avis d'ébullition d'eau à long
terme
après dix ans de monsieur harper whisky
à rien faire on a pu créer des nouvelles
écoles des nouveaux investissements en
partenariat justement avec les peuples
autochtones mais on comprend qu il faut
continuer il y en a beaucoup plus
à faire mais le grand chef de
l'assemblée des premières nations pays
bergen a reconnu qu' aucun gouvernement
n'a fait plus verts on reconnaît on en a
plus affaire à la bio et messieurs même
sur trous dont ce n'est pas vrai parce
que le trim tribune des doigts humaine à
un jugement et les avocats de notre
gouvernement votre gouvernement a
contesté la risotto ce n'est pas vrai
que je vous avais dit que vous avez à
l'aise avec la décision les avocats de
deux m'ont fait rire la santé un effort
de reverser le jugement en faveur des
enfants autochtones
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour ça c'est
un vrai scandale
on est d'accord avec le tribunal qu'il
faut compenser ses enfants on a encore
des problèmes on a là pourquoi ai je
sais je sais pas encore pourquoi avoir
fait appel je trouve parce que le
l'échéancier de le faire d'ici décembre
ne fonctionne pas avec les élections
qu'on est entraînante en découvrant
compenser ses enfants mais ça prend un
peu de temps pour l'avoir de la bonne
façon
j'ai créé ma comme un problème mais on a
encore des problèmes aujourd'hui il n'y
a pas de réserve tous les réserves n'ont
pas d'eau potable c'est pas une question
d'argent pour livrer ses services live
21 milliards de dollars que le grand
fédéral dépense dans les relations avec
les premières nations
il faut changer le système le set ce
coût ne fonctionne pas et ça fait des
années comme vous le dites qu'on essaie
de bâtir met en relation avec les
premières nations ce qu'il faut faire
c'est bien clair il faut abolir la loi
sur les indiens
il faut s'assurer qu'ils aient plus
d'autonomie sur les réserves
il faut s'assurer de développer un droit
de propriété sur les réserves
il faut qu'il y avait là richesse qui se
créent sur les réserves et oui il faut
aussi développer des pipelines pour
s'assurer en collaboration avec les
premières nations que la richesse puisse
arriver sur les réserves ces bonnes
questions et d'encore plus d'argent
c'est une question de changer notre
relation le site rue doria je suis tout
à fait d'accord qu'il faut passer au
delà de la loi sur les indiens
mais c'est à eux de décider le rythme
avec lequel ça se fait il ya plusieurs
communautés qui l'ont déjà fait on
travaille avec toutes les communautés
pour qu'ils puissent le faire mais à
leur rythme et dans le respect de leurs
priorités
très bien je veux vous les envoyez une
question je vais leur demander d'ouvrir
mais pour les six exceptionnellement en
régie parce que je veux vous poser la
question sur la culture on l'abordé trop
rapidement tout à l'heure vous promettez
un certain nombre d'entre vous promettez
ultra doux ça a été long mais vous
l'avez promis dans votre vos engagements
d'imposer ou taxer les géants du web
vous engagez vous à remettre cet argent
aux créateurs aux artistes qui
produisent des contenus et qu'ils
reçoivent
on va se dire des miettes qui reçoivent
des miettes tu te goures rapidement
chacun on va en faire plus que je sers
7la en investissement aux cultures des
deux propositions 3% de redevances et
prenez posséder redevance parce qu'ils
exploitent commercialement des contenus
qui leur appartiennent pas 3% des
centaines de millions de dollars par
année
réservé aux médias et à la culture et au
divertissement et aux artistes
forcément c'est dedans dont 40% réservé
au secteur francophone comme ça se fait
en me les rssi du sushi répondants
j'aurais dit de nommer monsieur on va
imposer une taxe sur les géants du web
qui ramasse beaucoup d'argent ici de
notre économie et on va assurer que cet
argent va pourra propres et nos
programmes est aussi on va créer une
nouveau régie pour le nouveau média
numérique parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
gens qui truquent réellement ne nous dit
rien aucune retenue parce que les gens
comme facebook nouveau gel de la dette
at il peur sur dernis moi je dis c'est
inéquitable actuellement que les gens ne
paient pas assez grand du web l'on ne
paie pas de tps il faut qu'ils la paient
comme les autres pays qui participent
aux et l'argent qu'on va voir nous c'est
la juridiction du canada après les
crises budgétaires oui on veut rêver ce
très bien madame et le film à venir pour
exactement ce que vous proposez pour
aider les artistes pour donner leurs
revenus vers notre prime unité
culturelle mais je vais acheter
seulement h aux basques jouent seconde
travaille comme un requin ce n'est pas
vrai que le mépris ministre à tikrit
ville du doigt et même pour les peuples
autochtones
c'est vraiment ouvert au gouvernement de
demander plus très bien je suis obligé
les problèmes et me suis trop d un flash
à gauche pendant la capen amateur a dit
tout ce qu'elle veut mais tu n'as la
douane quand il est au gouvernement
oui il faut taxer les géants du web et
oui il faut réinvestir dans la couture
pour les artistes pour lui
créateur oui fortement oui très bien
merci beaucoup je vous remercie de votre
collaboration je pense et éclairera pour
les gens qui nous regardent
j'appelle patricia cloutier bonsoir
patricia qui va vous poser des questions
aussi en rafale on va accélérer le
rythme des questions très concrètes
j'allais voir très intéressant patricia
pour appel j'attends des réponses
courtes 15 secondes environ
des millions de canadiens se sont fait
voler ces derniers mois des de leurs
données personnelles
êtes vous prêt à faire comme la grande
bretagne et à pénaliser les entreprises
responsables d'une fuite de données
mais si c'est oui bien sûr les banques
en responsable des gardes et la
privation des gens et quand on a des
situations qui arrive comme ça avec les
banques ou l'après vie c est brisé c'est
la responsabilité des banques et oui il
faut avoir des répercussions
merci monsieur trudeau oui on a créé une
charte pour la défendre les droits
numériques des citoyens on travaille
avec la grande bretagne et la france a
pour s'assurer que les citoyens puissent
avoir contrôle de leurs données
qui peut savoir le contrôle de leurs
informations merci monsieur blanchet lui
proposerons au parlement que les sûr on
va proposer au parlement de part que les
mesures d'identification des clients
soient beaucoup plus sévère deuxièmement
que les déclarations soient faites
chaque fois qu'une fuite de
renseignements il faut que l'entreprise
déclare le fuite de renseignements à la
fin de l'année qu'elle déclare
l'ensemble des futurs dans l'entreprise
et couvre les frais qui pourrait être
encourues par les clients très bien
monsieur vers nîmes oui à la protection
des renseignements personnels et aucune
entreprise est au dessus de la loi merci
madame mais c'est presque une année oui
bon on doit protéger les canadiens
contre les choses comme ça
les dunks sont négligents et on doit
protéger les droits des consommateurs
mais c'est cher maintenant oui on va
protéger les consommateurs les canadiens
et canadiennes et à assurer l'intégrité
de leurs données mais je dois dire que
c'est le groupement de justin trudeau
qui a donné essayé de donner le
proviseur statistics canada pour a
ramassé l'information sont conscientes
des canadiens c'est excessif c'est
canada voyons
les données des données financières
banquière vous avez donné l'absolution
pc seulement l'un porte sur nos
positions les dès maintenant la chaîne
question patriciens que ça qu'on n'est
pas dans un moment de débat j'ai une
autre question pour vous les canadiens
attendent depuis longtemps un trait à
grande fréquence entre québec et toronto
vous engagez vous à réaliser ce projet
de transport et si oui quand monsieur
singh la barre oui c'est un engagement
dans notre plateforme on a déjà engagé
sadin parce que ça touche comment on
peut faire face à la crise climatique
en investissant dans le transport en
commun donc oui on est tellement pur à
la crainte de latran écran fréquence
c'est un élément de comment on peut
réduire nos émissions de gaz à effet de
serre on peut le faire tout de suite
merci mais c'est rude autres si nous qui
chapeaute ans le projet on s'est assuré
que sa part par trois rivières que ça se
rende à à québec il ya encore du travail
à faire là dessus mais on est un
gouvernement qui a choisi d'investir
dans les infrastructures
contrairement au gouvernement
conservateur dont les provinces qui ne
veulent pas investir dans les
infrastructures
merci mais c'est blanche et dames ce
trailer c'est le sasquatch on en parle
tout le temps on ne le voit jamais il
était promis par les libéraux en 2015 je
me rappelle monsieur champagne faisait
même que salaire était à shawinigan et
l'oeil on dit quoi cette année à dia on
va peut-être faire une étude parce qu'on
n'est pas sûr on n'est pas sur le board
embarquer dans le train
merci de ces derniers tout le monde
promet les investissements avec de
l'argent qu'on n'a pas c'est de l'argent
qu'on à paris c'est bien vous le dire et
nous ce qu'on dit c'est que non il faut
équilibrer le budget en premier et on ne
commencera pas à plaire à tout le monde
la matière d'avoir des votes c'est pas
responsable de vouloir dépenser des
milliards de dollars quand le d'autres
d'autres choses à faire pour équilibrer
le budget avant merci madame mais merci
le déclic est absolument dans notre
pleine mission possible
on doit se permettre ce pied un système
de transports en commune ii côte à côte
à côte particulièrement entre 30 au
québec et aussi prendre et demandant
avec un bruit
nous avons un système de trois fois en
cabine qui s'est vraiment pour le
mexique
merci enfin monsieur scheer seulement
60% des fonds du programme défaut
structure ils sont dépensés sur les
grands projets oui j'ai eu une
discussion avec yves lévesque notre
candidat at revient on a pris ce projet
parce qu'elle a aidés dans la croissance
économique à vous rendre la vie plus
simple pour les gens des régions et on
va le faire paraître ambitieux trop
kiffé les promesses mais louise s'il
pourra prendre le train un jour c'est
pas tout à fait car mon prof merci
beaucoup merci alors prochain thème
[Musique]
politique étrangère et immigration nous
débutons avec un citoyen il est à dieppe
au nouveau brunswick philippe marcil je
crois que j'étais à l'université de
moncton monsieur marcel bonsoir à vous
les chefs vous écoute votre question
bonsoir des chefs comme vous le savez
avec les événements qui se déroulent à
hong kong d'emprisonnement des deux
canadiens et les nombreux manquements
face aux droits humains en chine
seriez vous prêt à cesser les échanges
commerciaux si la situation ne
s'améliore pas merci beaucoup pour votre
question première réponse monsieur
bernier oui la priorité est bien clair
c'est de faire en sorte que les
canadiens puissent être retour au canada
est actuellement bien qu est ce qui
arrive c'est les relations avec la chine
qui sont tirées pas leurs meilleurs sons
peut dire mais pas seulement la chine
avec d'autres pays à cause du
gouvernement trudeau
donc ça serait une priorité comment
faire ben oui il faut avoir l'oeil de
nos alliés mais aussi en maintenant
regarder nos relations commerciales avec
la chine
et ça peut être quelque chose qu'on va
évaluer pour imposer d'autres des tarifs
si jamais on n'a pas la réponse à ce
qu'on veut c'est rapatrier ces canadiens
le plus rapidement possible et aussi ce
que je peux vous rajoutez sait que c'est
important de s'assurer qu'on a des
bonnes relations avec l'ensemble des
autres pays
ce qu'avec monsieur trudeau avec les
états unis on n'a pas la meilleure
entente et avec l'inde aussi c'est en
clair si merci monsieur bernier monsieur
trudeau on reconnaît que la priorité
c'est toujours de défendre les intérêts
des canadiens et de défendre les
canadiens c'est pour ça qu'on a
justement fait activé tous nos alliés
autour de la planète pour mettre la
pression sur la chine pour leur dire que
non ça ne se fait pas de détenir de
façon arbitraire des canadiens pour une
raison politique
on va continuer de chercher à résoudre
cet enjeu tout en reconnaissant que la
chine est une économie en croissance qui
prend beaucoup plus de place qui crée
des opportunités économiques pour nos
producteurs pour nos travailleurs mais
nous devons toujours et
là pour défendre nos valeurs nos
principes et c'est ce que nous allons
toujours faire merci monsieur toure dur
mais sushi c'est pas une grande surprise
que le gourmand de la chine ne respecte
pas justin trudeau après de son voyage
désastreux
on a beaucoup des chefs d'état du g20
qui ne respectent pas mr doit arriver
pour prenant neuf mois pour protéger les
canadiens et les canadiennes pour les
intérêts des canadiens
j'ai dit que quand premier jeu va
retirer l'argent canadien de la banque
d'infrastructures asiatiques
il ya occupé c'est une banque qui était
contrôlé par le gouvernement de la chine
n'y a aucune bonne raison pour l'argent
des contribuables d'être et d'aller pour
construire les ponts et les routes dans
les autres pays et qui appuient la
politique étrangère de la chine
on va y revenir à ça monsieur things
will à la créolité si les canadiens qui
à ce moment sont dans une situation
tellement difficile donc il faut agir
dès maintenant pour les aider ça c'est
quelque chose qui qui est essentielle en
plus oui à la question sur qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire avec la chine
il faut être fort pour montrer qui on
défend les droits de la personne ce qui
se passe encore c'est tellement
inquiétant le fait que les gens à fond
face des grands auprès nations contre le
3 mai avec monsieur trudeau encore on
voit qu'ils doivent flashé à gauche
pendant la cabane dit où les bonnes
choses mais il va tourner à droite
pendant qu'il est au gouvernement ce que
je vais dire pourquoi elle a pas arrêté
devant des armes
merci nous avons un éléphant dans le
chambre c'est le traître que monsieur a
accepté avec la chine c'est dont le
parlement deux derniers essais dit
jamais j'avais dont les débats de
prononcer par un seul vote c'est une
très très énorme avec les investisseurs
de la république la chine qui a donné
déjà les doigts des entreprises de la
chine de charger le cadre quand nous
avons les lois que le chine n'aime pas
contre les lois pour protéger
l'environnement et c'est tout à fait
on s'est créé c'est quelque chose merci
merci monsieur blanchet finalement
amèrement d'avoir une pensée pour les
agriculteurs sous gestion de l'offre de
la circonscription de l'échangé et de la
vallée du richelieu parce que de
mauvaises négociations commerciales le
rock tv 2 points 4 % leurs parts de
marché après ça le gouvernement canadien
s'est fait l'instrument des états unis
et ses poignets une chicane avec la
chine malheureusement la réponse c'est
qu'on peut pas être chic en perpétuelle
avec un géant comme on peut pour jouer
des brocs avec la chine malheureusement
c'est impossible
et là c'est les producteurs de porcs de
soya et de canola qui paie le prix de sa
alors malheureusement il faut maintenir
une relation commerciale avec la chine
j'espère qu'on pourra revenir aussi sur
un autre de l'arabie saoudite le
traitement de rêve pas d'un oui la vente
d'armes à l'arabie saoudite saoudite qui
choque beaucoup de gens au québec
il faut que ça cesse merci monsieur
blanchet alors monsieur marcel merci
beaucoup de votre question et non
poursuivons sur le thème alors on va on
va poursuivre sur ce thème de la
chesnaie sur cette crise diplomatique
depuis donc dix mois maintenant où vient
de faire mention de ça il ya deux
canadiens qui sont emprisonnés en chine
en représailles à l'arrestation de même
wenzhou la directrice financière de
huawei messieurs vous voulez durcir le
ton envers la chine a imposé des tarifs
douaniers
est ce que c'est la méthode drame de
vous proposer partout c'est c'est une
contraste méthode inaction de justin
trudeau
parce que c'est clair que pendant cette
crise il n'a rien fait et a il a pris
neuf mois de nommer nouveaux
ambassadeurs et elle a pris neuf mois
seulement
juste avant le déclenchement des
élections qu'il a fait il ya une crainte
pour la tribune au mondial pour le
commerce à dire que mon approche
on va remontrer on va montrer aux le
gouvernement de la chine convainc
défendre nos intérêts on va défendre nos
producteurs agricoles et on va défendre
les canadiens qui sont détenus et une
chose je dois dire le l'excusent pendant
cette crise de pain auprès du
gouvernement de ne pas ingérer dans les
affaires de l'exécutif de huawei c'est
que le gouvernement ne peut pas le
premier ne peut pas gérer dans une
poursuite criminelle
mais prend dans la sphère de sensio labs
c'est justin trudeau qui a essayé de
gérer associés nourrir notre position
versus le gouvernement de la chine parce
qu'on est rectorat il a dit quelque
chose mais faire les choses de raison la
comparaison faisons la comparaison le
canada ont à peu près le même poids
relatif face à la chine face aux états
unis où face à l'europe est toujours eu
et les relations commerciales avec
l'europe ou l'asie
on fonctionnait relativement bien
pourquoi est-ce que récemment ça s'est
mis à les tout croche
ça saigne à aller tout croche parce que
la crédibilité de l'interlocuteur et ça
compte la crédibilité de l'interlocuteur
n'est pas à la hauteur du un discrédit
international ce que fait que le
président des états unis peut quitter
une rencontre ni un communiqué qu'ils
étaient émis se moquer du premier
ministre du canada
je pense qu'une question de respect
qu'un pays est quand même un pays
dangereux doit exiger subi la politique
étrangère du canada doit être beau être
axés sur la sécurité la prospérité des
canadiens et j'aimerais faire remarquer
que de ce thème si c'est politique
étrangère et immigration et je suis seul
ici sur le plateau qui est prêt à faire
en sorte à dire oui au gouvernement le
goas concerne l'immigration le
gouvernement legault veut ainsi des
migrations plus bas et s'assurer d'avoir
deux grands économique monsieur chez on
veut toujours avoir plus plus
d'immigrants est d'accord avec monsieur
trudeau a350 1000 par année
il n'avait pas de solution pour régler
la route les gens qui passent
illégalement à la route roxane et ça
c'est important ça c'est pour s'assurer
sur les migrations d'ailleurs monsieur
bernier c'est clair on le sait il veut
baisser les seuils d'immigration vous
c'est quoi votre solution là dessus que
j'ai fait un grand tonné de du québec à
l'écouté québécois dans chaque endroit
j'ai entendu la même chose est en
pénurie de main d'oeuvre
est ce que c'est travailler avec
monsieur la gauche pour donner plus
d'autonomie au québec pour les
migrations et je suis le seul préfet et
je dois dire que avec plusieurs députés
bloquistes
on ne peut pas faire parce que justin
trudeau va rester comme premier semestre
avec les sièges bloquiste ça va garantir
que justin trudeau va continuer sur le
deuxième but
je ne vais pas que la pression se régler
la situation à nos frontières support
chine va t on nous tue la à voter pour
le bloc c'est voter pour les libéraux à
voter pour le bloc c'est voter pour les
conservateurs voter pour le bloc
c'est vrai pour le québec disposera ça
va dans un parlement c'est une
démocratie première chose deuxième chose
monsieur legault et le gouvernement du
québec a demandé clairement les pouvoirs
pour une précision le mercredi
après-midi les pouvoirs en immigration
là-dessus sécurité c'est ce que vous
devriez vous engager tout le monde a
compris au québec notamment pour les
enjeux économiques zew sur l'immigration
nous aimer prétendre d'être le meilleur
ami de monsieur locaux mais on est mieux
ce soit et en est après l'érection
nouvelle vous allez travailler
monsieur chez vous tous les attributs
sais pas quoi le bloc des jeux blancs
voici le meilleur exemple d'une
cacophonie
les gens n'ont rien puis second non j'ai
pas quand son jeu qu'il a été
inéquitable là dessus ce qui est de dire
c'est que monsieur scheer n'est pas
d'accord avec monsieur legault qui va
avoir des entrevues avec chaque
immigrant qui veut s'assurer d'avoir un
test de valeurs qui sont pas d'accord un
crétin sa valeur c'est vrai est en train
de dire aujourd'hui qui va régler la
route roxane vous ne réglez pas ici on
veut vraiment avoir plus une grande
nature économique
il faut avoir moins des réfugiés et
c'est ce qu'on veut faire on veut aider
les vrais réfugiés voulant viande en
raison de ce dernier merci monsieur
bernier juge il 10 secondes monsieur
blanchet 10 secondes je vais appris à
utiliser les réfugiés qui quittent la
guerre civile qui quittent les désastres
naturels par qui vient de l'état de new
york et je vais régler le fait dans le
temps de les faire appliquer les mêmes
principes dans l'est dans les bois les
endroits comme maximum on va assurer que
notre système qu'on se serait montrée
soulagée
deux choses appliquer l'article 10 de
l'entente entre les tiers pays sûrs pour
fermer le chemin oxame et forcer les
gens à penser par les vrais poissons aux
qualifs c'est selon lui l'esprit la
démocratie c'est solide jacques
bourgeois très bien autre trio autres
trios monsieur singh madame et monsieur
trudeau monsieur trudeau jean on
poursuit la discussion sur l'immigration
est ce que j'ai prêt à donner les
pouvoirs que le premier du québec vous
demandant ni en immigration
il ya l'histoire du test des valeurs il
ya aussi la possibilité de baisser les
seuils pour une catégorie d'immigrants
on a travaillé et monsieur legault
abaisser les seuils à d'immigration
foule au québec parce que le québec a
beaucoup de pouvoirs en matière
d'immigration plus que toute autre
province si c'est une bonne chose
à cause de l'identité québécoise et la
protection de la langue est d'ailleurs
s'ils veulent appliquer un test lors du
certificat de sélection
c'est tout à fait correct et s'est
approprié qu'il le fasse
on reconnaît l'importance que le quai de
gouvernements de québec et plus de
contrôle sur l'immigration c'est quelque
chose que nous nous avons toujours bien
travailler avec le gouvernement du
québec depuis quatre ans dessus
très bien trio vers les verts nous
sommes absolument ouvert de parler avec
monsieur legault parce que newscom vers
nous sommes absolument engager de
travailler avec la nation québécoise
d'égal à égal
mais au niveau fédéral au niveau pro
tour notre pays nous sommes engagés pour
augmentation des niveaux d émigration à
cause de deux choses nous avons nous
avons besoin des travailleurs et
travailleuses et en même temps nous
avons les obligations parce que nous
sommes un pays industry is et nous avons
contribué plus que notre nombre des
populations de crise climatique et nous
avons le problème des réfugiés
climatiques
c'est bien monsieur si oui on est prêt
de travail avec le québec c'est
tellement important on va mieux financer
les mieux intégration des gens mais
quelque chose machel est un peu monsieur
blanchet a dit voter pour le bloc ci
beauté pour le québec et ses mashaal un
peu parce que oui le bloc c'est vous
mais le québec c'est une diversité
d'opinions
c'est une diversité des régions c'est
une diversité de voix que vous n'avez
pas un monopole sur lequel polonais
l'aixois des taux vous n'avez pas mon
amour qui est d'ailleurs j'avais
justement dire la même chose parce que
je suis fier québécois et je suis
fédéraliste et je suis fier canadien est
ce qu'on a vu en 2015 c'est que les
québécois ont choisi de faire partie
d'un gouvernement et c'est ça qui a mis
fin à dix ans de monsieur harper qui
n'investissent pas en culture qui coupe
est partout et qui proposait l'austérité
est maintenant que le bloc veut
reprendre une place et vous et les
québécois encore une fois à l'opposition
les québécois devraient doivent
réfléchir très très clairement
est ce qu'ils veulent faire faire partie
d'un gouvernement qui va continuer à
lutter contre les changements
climatiques a travaillé main dans la rue
sur des priorités communes c'est
exactement ce qu'on fait depuis quatre
ans est ce qu'on va continuer dans le
monsieur trudeau c'est clair que vous
donnent des barbares ont maintenant mais
en fait vous êtes premier ministre de
vos petits amis vous avez rencontré des
secteurs pétroliers 1500 fois et puis
après ce n'était pas un hasard que vous
avez acheté un pipeline camille avec on
arrive et on est vraiment déçu
hier mais ce 5 permettez-moi n'est pas
sur le sujet on était sur l'immigration
j'ai accepté parce que l'immigration
pouvoirs du québec ça a débordé mais
l'on revient pas au public mais remercie
monsieur voix au sujet des migrations
mais monsieur trudeau vous avez fait
quelque chose que vous allez prenez
jamais fait et ça c'est de cacher les
lois dans les projets loi omnibus
budgétaires et dans le dernier projet
loi omnibus budgétaire vous avez caché
les choses avec invitation des droits
des réfugiés donc caché dans un projet
de loi omnibus
nous avons les choses qui arrêtait les
doigts humaine à lui les les doigts et
même des personnes qui veut faire
chercher un vide sécuritaire et six au
canada
c'est tout à fait refaire de mana mais
nous comprenons que les canadiens
croient qu'on devrait avoir un système
rigoureux et équitable qui s'applique à
tout le monde et on est en train de
suivre toutes les normes et on est entré
en train de mener énorme à
l'international pour protéger les droits
de la personne pour s'assurer que tout
le monde qui arrive dans nos frontières
que ce soit de façon régulière ou
irrégulière passe par l'intégrité de
notre système d'immigration
on a un système fort qui continuent à
s'appliquer mais il ya des gens qui mise
sur la peur et la division la séparation
des solutions claires pour régler la
problème de le traverser la frontière et
régulé ça c'est de suspendre l'accord
des tiers pays sûrs mais vous n'avez pas
de courage de le faire parce que vous
n'avez le courage de dénoncer quelques
comme trempe qui met des enfants dans
des prisons ce n'est pas sécuritaire
pour eux
pourquoi ne vous n'avez vous n'avez pas
le courage de dire noah trempe de
suspendre deux tiers piscine jacuzzi le
faire si vite et de parler des relations
avec les états unis parce qu'on est dans
une situation de relations
internationales et les relations avec
les américains c'est la relation la plus
importante pour un 1er ministre canadien
ou pour un pays seront nature c'est sûr
dans un moment de protectionnisme et en
arabe et des villages châteaux la
question s'était plaint des approches de
la gestion de leur faisait augmenter les
prix des médicaments vous est versé
paris merci monsieur scène la question
du second c'était l'accord sur les tiers
pays sûrs oui parce que ils sont il peut
pas s'ouvrir aux continue de le
travailler avec les américains
castonguay va se joindre à moi pour
poser des questions donc à chacun des
chefs en rafale allaient castonguay chef
du bureau politique d'une actualité au
soir bonsoir messieurs bonsoir madame
première question pour monsieur trudeau
plusieurs citoyens nous ont écrit parce
qu'ils sont inquiets et préoccupés par
la cinquantaine de migrants qui arrivent
chaque jour sur le chemin loxam à la
frontière canadienne
est ce que pour vous c'est un problème
oui c'est un problème parce que on a on
est dans un monde maintenant ou 60 65
millions de personnes sont des migrants
sondés sont des gens déplacés
quand on reconnaît qu'on a une
responsabilité de passer ces gens là
dans l'intégrité dans tant de façon
rigoureuse dans notre système
d'immigration
et si ce qu'on fait on a fait les
investissements nécessaires il n'y a pas
de passe-droit à la frontière tout le
monde qui vient de façon régulière ou
irrégulière à ces vérifications de
sécurité et passe dans toutes les étapes
de notre système d'immigration
merci monsieur trudeau mal à me le
réchauffement climatique est un problème
planétaire et pas seulement canadiens
dans les dix prochaines années
la chine prévoit ouvrir six nouvelles
chante centrales au charbon chaque mois
comment s'assurer que les efforts
canadiens ne sont pas anéanti annulés
par les autres pays c'est pas possible
pour moi de donner en garantie me suis
absolument certain que ce quart d'heure
gascon maintenant comme un pays
terrorisé riches qui sont absolument
engager de augmenter les niveaux de gaz
à effet de serre c'est impossible pour
nous de jouer un rôle dans le monde dont
les négociations des nations unies
nous avons eu tout le temps passe et le
rôle de l'erreur nous avons perdu ce
rôle à cause de notre absolument une
échelle contre les désastres changement
climatique je suis certain qu'avec à
plein comme mission possible
nous pouvons encore jouer un rôle comme
leader
merci madame et monsieur bernier vous
souhaitez que le canada
accueil - des migrants moins de réfugiés
souhaité couper dans l'aide aux pays
pauvres
vous souhaitez vous désengager de l'onu
est ce que le canada a un rôle à jouer
dans le monde
effectivement le cas dans un rôle à
jouer dans le monde avec ses alliés mais
d'abord faut aider les canadiens en
premier c'est ce qui est important
et en ce qui concerne l'immigration vous
avez raison d'en parler parce que
monsieur trudeau a laissé sous-entendre
tout à l'heure que notre position sur
l'immigration et une position radicale
lorsque 49 % des canadiens veulent un
seuils d'immigration plus bas et on est
seul parti ainsi qu'ils en parlent
on est seulement 6% les canadiens
veulent encore plus et plus
d'immigration
nous ce qu'on dit il faut orienter sa
sur l'immigration de nature économique
ayant un coût il ya un coût social avoir
toujours plus et plus d'immigration
regard des jeux sur les maisons le prix
des maisons à toronto et aussi à
vancouver
41 % des immigrants vont lancer grandes
villes là et ça fait une pression à la
hausse sur les logements là bas donc il
faut s'assurer d'avoir un seuil plus bas
merci monsieur scheer vous souhaitez
diminué de 25 % l'aide aux pays pauvres
ce qui ramènerait la contribution
canadienne à son niveau de 1965
est-ce que vous tournez pas le dos à la
tradition canadienne pas du tout on va
éliminer 25% de l'idée étrange et qui à
ce moment avant à les pays relativement
avec les revenus élevés
on va garder cette oreille garder cet
argent ici pour vendre la vie plus
abordable pour les qualifier on va payer
pour notre best épaules universelle
c'est 850 $ pour une coupe l'heure de
revenir à moyenne et on va éliminer la
tps sur les factures dans le ciel des
troupes et tousser et tout ça en coupant
l'aide au pays beau et aussi les
subventions coopératif et aussi on va
avoir d'autres plateformes tout chiffré
bientôt si c'est au contraire que le che
trudeau qui cache les chiffres de pro
plus de 50% de ses engagements
merci monsieur monsieur blanchet vous
avez dit que le canada aurait dû se
mêler de ses affaires et ne pas arrêter
la directrice financière de huawei
wenzhou à la demande des états unis
selon vous est ce que la règle de droit
est négociable en fonction de la
puissance du client ou du pays je pense
que c'était pas simple de même
la réalité est que les états unis ont
invoqué des règles de droit qui rentrait
dans des notions de commerce était pas
le geste criminel c'était vraiment lié à
des sanctions ces complexes très liés à
des sanctions que le canada ne pas
cautionner et lorsque tu embarques sur
une patinoire comme ça contre un
adversaire ça devient un adversaire
aussi puissant que la chine et que c'est
des agriculteurs du québec des
agriculteurs de l'ouest qui paie le prix
de sa tu te comporter de façon que je
qualifierais d'irresponsable on y pense
aux conséquences et les américains sont
pas venus aider le ghana comment ils ont
fait pour faire respecter nos traités
d'extradition si on répond pas à nos
amis qui eux demandent dans le caudrésis
était traité d'extradition c'est un
enjeu d'extradition liés à des sanctions
commerciales imposées par les américains
quitte à pauli a déjà ses ailes vers six
nations non je me suis blanche et
monsieur singh chaque fois que le canada
singh un accord commercial que ce soit
avec les états unis où avec l'europe
le npd s'y opposent êtes vous libre
échangiste ou protectionniste
donc pour moi cette question dès
qu'elles sortent d'un échange au mois ci
la chance d'un avantage et aux
travailleurs travaillent c'est bon mais
ce qu'on a vu avec monsieur trudeau il
veut avoir des échanges et aussi avec
monsieur scheer comme un conservateur
elle veut avoir des échanges qui donnent
tout de pouvoir tout le bénéfice aux
plus riches mais ça n'aide pas pas de
tous les travailleurs à travers ce que
je veux voir céder à cordes où on dans
des bénéfices des avantages pour les
travailleurs et travailleuses
parce que je ne travaille pas pour les
plus riches je travaille pour vous les
gens mais monsieur singh l'europe et les
états unis ont quand même des valeurs
qui ressemble au canada pour les
travailleurs pourquoi ne pas être
d'accord avec ces accords là donc par
exemple avec l'alena on ait eu des
brèches dans la gestion nov
on a eu une augmentation de prix des
médicaments et finalement pas des
protections laissant mayer ou
l'environnement
merci mais je sais merci à tous et merci
beaucoup prochain thème
[Musique]
identité éthique et gouvernance nous
lançons le thème avec une question d'une
citoyenne elle est à montréal lise
pigeons bonsoir madame pigeons bonsoir
patrice alors nous vous écoutons les
chefs vous écoute votre question j'ai 63
ans je suis atteint de sclérose en
plaques depuis près de 30 ans et surtout
d'arthrite rhumatoïde sévère depuis 12
ans je ne marche plus je souffre je
porte des culottes d'incontinence
j'ai des plaies de pression et j'en
passe madame et messieurs afin de
permettre à vos proches et à nous tous
un jour d'avoir le droit de mourir dans
la dignité
permettez vous aux électeurs oui ou non
d'alléger la loi actuelle comme le
recommande la juge baudoin de la cour
supérieure du québec
mais ce bien sûr s'ancrer d'embûches
supplémentaires merci merci infiniment
madame pigeon je vous reviens après les
réponses
madame et vous êtes la première à
répondre à un terme aux gens je suis
vraiment touchée par votre situation et
je veux donner à vos mails sympathie est
aussi un engagement parce qu'on doit
changer sa loi
j'ai fait mes affaires dont le parlement
dont l'étude de le projet loi pour
permettre à l'aidant moururent est là
d'imiter les droits des citoyens de
choisir de façon à les moments de mort
en vérité je veux faire encore les mêmes
choses dont le prochain parlement
merci madame et monsieur singh madame ma
réponse est oui
et merci infiniment pour avoir le
courage de partager une question assez
difficile et pour partager vos histoires
qui aussi tellement difficile ça prend
beaucoup de courage et je veux vous
remercier
c'est clair avec le jugement au québec
que les critères sont trop limitées et
ça ne donne pas là d'une idée donc ce
que je veux faire
ces deux enlever les limites parce que
c'est trop limité je veux vous donner
plus de pouvoir d'avoir le droit de
mourir dans la dignité
c'est une décision difficile mais il
faut avoir accès trois importants donc
oui je suis avec vous et oui on peut le
faire
merci monsieur shing monsieur blanchet
la réponse est très évidemment oui c'est
un phénomène très nouveau c'est une loi
c'est une philosophie nouvelle au québec
comme au canada et je vous félicite et
je félicite les gens qui sont allés au
tribunal parce que vous vous êtes
emparés de cette toile
vous avez dit maintenant c'est à nous
ils ont aussi participé à commence à
votre ligne
pire comment ça va s'appliquer je pense
que le gouvernement les gouvernements
doivent s'engager fermement à respecter
le jugement sans condition qui est à
travailler en parallèle par la suite à
continuer à bonifier ces lois là il est
essentiel que le jugement soit respectée
merci monsieur blanchet monsieur trudeau
merci madame pigeons pour votre question
et pour votre courage d'être avec nous
si ce soir c'est une question
extrêmement personnel pour les individus
pour les familles et nous devons être là
en tant que gouvernement pour vous aider
à naviguer ces questions difficiles
oui nous allons alléger la loi dans les
prochains six mois parce que nous
reconnaissons depuis le début que
c'était une nouvelle loi un équilibre
qu'il fallait chercher entre la
protection des plus vulnérables et le
respect des droits et des choix de
chacun chacune et on comprenait même i à
iii 3 4 ans quand on a mené seule cette
voie là que les tribunaux la société
tout allait évoluer et nous on va
évoluer avec merci votre question merci
monsieur triaud mais soucieux aussi
merci beaucoup pour la question est un
bon courage à vous avez tous mes
sympathies à céret vais donc ça c'est
l'enjeu très près sain et je dois dire
que ce c'est une des moments que j'ai
trouvé que tous les partis au parlement
a vraiment essayé de trouver à l'hôtel
lebon voix pour répondre aux allées aux
décisions de court mais en même temps de
troubles trouvé l'écho libre pour
protéger les régions vulnérables et
choses comme ça et âprement nous allons
toujours respecté les décisions de court
en même temps on va faire une revue de
la décision et de tva que régis parce
que monsieur blanchet a dit ça c'est
vrai tellement nouveau système rigide si
aucun d'endroits à ce qu'on trouve de
bons voire merci monsieur chouf
conclusion monsieur bernier oui
effectivement cette fois là doit être
révisée moi je peux vous dire que j'ai
voté en faveur au fédéral de la loi sur
aude mourir avec dignité et on prendre
la liberté et la responsabilité
individuelle au parti populaire
je m'apprête effectivement à m'engager à
regarder cette législation là et
s'assurer que les gens qui prennent
cette décision difficile avec leur père
soit capable de faire ce qu'ils veulent
faire pour leur fin de vie
donc vous avez complètement l'appui du
parti populaire dans votre démarche
merci monsieur bernier merci surtout
madame pigeon vous êtes la plus
courageuse d'entre nous ce soir ici
merci beaucoup
d'avoir eu le courage de venir nous
parler chez que c'était pas facile
nécessairement et c'est un débat
important et qui va suivre son cours on
vient de l'entente
merci madame pigeon bonne fin de soirée
merci merci nous poursuivons avec la
première confrontation à 3 monsieur
singh monsieur trudeau et monsieur
bernie inutile de vous dire qu'on a reçu
une tonne de questions sur la laïcité je
vous repose à vous trois et je le ferai
aux trois autres la question assez
simplement allez-vous intervenir dans la
contestation de la loi 21 sur la laïcité
et si oui à quelle étape donnez nous des
détails parce qu'on a l'impression que
vous êtes tellement prudent pour ne pas
perdre de vote au québec que ça devient
tellement confus votre discours je vous
en prie
soyez clair monsieur singh je commence
avec vous oui d'accord j'étais toujours
clair je ne veux pas intervenir dans je
ne veux pas intervenir
est ce que je veux faire c'est de
toujours lutté contre la concept
division je suis contre évidemment
l'idée de discrimination moi je pense
que je pensais beaucoup de gens qui font
face est cette discrimination dans leur
vie c'est complètement inacceptable
mais je veux gagner le coeur des gens
donc je suis au québec je suis à travers
le pays et je parle aux gens et j'ai dit
oui parce je porte un taux bas mais je
suis pour la loi d'avortement
je suis pour le droit de mourir dans la
dignité je suis pour la lutte contre la
crise climatique
et oui je porte un turban mais je
partage vos valeurs c'est une question
de valeurs
donc si on veut protéger la société il
faut renforcer les droits des femmes il
faut renforcer le droit d'abord
l'avortement
ça c'est comment on peut créer une
société plus juste et je suis prêt pour
la faire je trouve j'ai toujours été
clair moi aussi que nous
n'interviendrons pas à cette étape ci
parce que c'est une question où les
québécois sont en train de
mettre au défi devant les tribunaux
cette loi qu'ils trouvent injuste mais
je trouve aussi que ce serait
irresponsable a pour un gouvernement
fédéral de fermer la porte à tout jamais
à intervenir dans un cas de à une étape
futur dans un cas de liberté de droits
fondamentaux
on devrait être là pour protéger des
francophones en dehors du québec
on devrait être là pour protéger les
droits des femmes les droits des
communautés lgbt ou bien les droits à
des minorités religieuses
je vais toujours défendre les droits de
tout le monde et on verra aux prochaines
étapes
même si toulon vient nous dire qu'il va
intervenir
et puis monsieur signe que dit le
contraire de ce qu'avait dit en anglais
récemment
moi je peux vous dire que j'ai une
parole et effectivement les six mois
terminés je peux vous dire que j'ai une
parole et on n'interviendra pas c'est
une décision du québec la laïcité au
québec est un fait maintenant ça passe
c'est passé dans une législation et il
faut respecter ça le québec a ses
propres juridictions le propre
compétence de passer une loi sur la
laïcité et nous nous allons la respecter
nous allons pas intervenir comme va
faire monsieur trudeau comme il vient de
le dire
et monsieur singh en anglais avait dit
le contraire c'est important de
souligner pop
messieurs si vous avez dit en conférence
de presse avait après le dernier débat
que à l'étape de la cour suprême nous
interviendrions alors vous préciser
exactement dit j'ai répété seulement un
fait mais surtout de là dit il ya un
fait et je l'a répété mais ce que je
j'ai dit clairement je ne veux pas
intervenir il y en pour suite je ne veux
pas intervenir
ce que je veux faire c'est de gagner le
coeur des gens j'ai toujours dit ça et
je veux faire ça parce que je sais que
la politique de division
ce n'est pas bon pour la société tout à
fait de la chaire est clair que une
possibilité d'une intervention
éventuelle mais c'est pas garanti
monsieur bernier parce que nous allons
laisser les étapes suivent leur cours
mais pensez-y je pense que les canadiens
s'attendent à ce qu'un gouvernement
fédéral soit là pour défendre les
communautés francophones si par exemple
un gouvernement majoritaire conservateur
de john ford s'attaque aux comptes aux
francophones en ontario
on s'attend que
fédéral tienne parole pour défendre les
droits des femmes contre un gouvernement
conservateur qui descend on sera là pour
défendre les droits fondamentaux de tout
le monde
monsieur bernier conclusions d'études
donc la conclusion est bien simple on
veut intervenir on veut empêcher et
faire en sorte que le consensus au
québec qui exigeait sur la loi de la
laïcité ne soit pas respecté et c'est
votre position un fédéral qui vont
intervenir le gouvernement fédéral qui
va dire au québec quoi faire dans ses
propres champs de compétences et nous au
parti populaire on veut respecter
monsieur trudeau la conscience
contrairement vous on veut pas s'ingérer
le québec a pris une décision le
gouvernement a pris une décision avec un
courage politique que monsieur legault
et le blanc du québec connu moi je
respecte cette décision là et il ya un
consensus et quand vous très sucré
minutes de jeu mais je dois toucher les
droits des femmes donc c'est une chose
de dire que oui on protège les droits
des femmes l'autre chose de le faire
maintenant au nouveau brunswick
ils ont en train de fermer la seul
endroit où on accès aux services de
doigts d'avortement mais vous n'avez
fait rien pour protéger accès aux
services d'avortement en
nouveau-brunswick comment vous pouvez
dire une chose en public oui je suis pas
le droit mais en privé ce que vous
faites ce n'est pas là monsieur trudeau
là dessus sur la dernière clinique
d'avortement effectivement prévu nous
sommes préoccupés par la décision du
gouvernement conservateur au nouveau
brunswick qui retourne en arrière sur
les droits des femmes
on avait travaillé avec l'ancien
gouvernement libéral au nouveau
brunswick pour améliorer l'accès à
l'avortement l'on voit un gouvernement
conservateur qui s'est fait élire qui
n'est pas là pour défendre les droits
des femmes et c'est ça le danger pour
défendre les droits des phares eh bien
merci beaucoup à vous deux trop deuxième
trio sur le sujet et on va poursuivre
donc avec madame aime ce cher monsieur
blanchet et je veux rapidement rester
sur l'avortement on va revenir à la
laïcité mais je veux rester sur
l'avortement une seconde monsieur scheer
vous engagez vous à améliorer l'accès à
l'avortement
malgré
vos convictions vos convictions pour vie
pour la dernière fois je vais à dire
j'ai toujours été clair sur cette
question
je suis personnellement promis mais on
ne va pas changer
l'accès ou les lois c'est la même chose
pendant les dernières un premier
ministre libéral consulter aux saveurs
ne va pas changer sous mon leadership si
comme je suis pro b les premiers s'en va
pas changer la loi ou l'accès un point
final
voilà monsieur blanchet je reviens vous
la laïcité et j'ai une question pour
vous et j'ai une question pour vous et
je vais relancer le trio
si la cour suprême invalide est la loi
québécoise sur la laïcité en tout ou en
partie
est-ce que selon vous ça relancerait
l'option souverainiste
je sais pas qu'est ce que les québécois
ferait dans ce col haut mais pour les
québécois la notion de laïcité c'est une
valeurs progressistes héritée de la
révolution tranquille c'est généreux
c'est accueillant ces bienveillant ça
protège légalité tout le monde ça
protège l'égalité des sexes c'est pas
quelque chose de contraignant ou de
restrictif dans le coeur et la tête des
québécois
j'appris ceux qui reconnaissent que
c'est à québec de décider
je comprends les ambiguïtés monsieur 5
vous dit pas la même affaire en français
par mag les légionelles nous avons
travaillé sa peau de m feinte puis quand
on parle de laïcité mais surtout nous
parle du nouveau brunswick du droit à
l'avortement
les québécois sont capables d'avoir des
gens avec lesquels ils reportent de
doutes quant à l'engagement sur la
laïcité est ce que les jeunes qui se
ferait virer de bord encore une fois par
la cour suprême se dirait qu on a été
comment dire négliger eu un manque de
respect institutionnels par la plus
haute instance juridique du canada et y
en a sûrement qui se poseraient la
question mais je suis convaincu que tel
n'est pas l'intention du gouvernement le
goût qui n'est pas un gouvernement
souverainiste
hier seulement moi qui étais qui peut
être premier mais ce qui était toujours
clair sur cette question
on ne veut pas devenir veut pas ne va
pas c'est mon position de premier jeu de
le convaincre
c'est mon premier et mon position
rougerie et ça va être ma position après
l'élection mais c'est clair que
la priorité de monsieur branché c'est de
réanimer le mouvement souverainiste
il va travailler avec le parti québécois
le lendemain après l'élection pour
relancer les débattre pour une autre
référendum c'est son priorité ça c'est
clair
non mais oui aussi je ne veux pas
entraîné mais je pense que c'est
vraiment un peu des arts dans ces
élections fédérales
je suis d'accord avec chantal hébert qui
a écrit v aujourd'hui que ce n'est pas
un enjeu dont une élection ce terreur et
nous avons eu le débat au sujet de loi
je pense que plus que le crise
climatique tente où cette élection pour
ça je suis inquiète je vous j'espère que
là le québécois le québec comme nation
reste une société inclusive
je pense que c'est une question paul et
québec est les québécois et les
québécoises mais maintenant si tu s'il
vous plaît nous avons uni reste discutée
qu'est-ce que passe pour les personnes
dans le nord du canada lactique
les personnes dont les régions
atlantiques
les questions posées un tiers sénéfiand
dans les débats après quelques cinq ans
sur cette loi parce que je dis quelque
chose tellement bizarre on pas de la loi
21 au québec et a commencé de parler
d'eux les autres enjeux de les autres
promesses et était obsédé de les
politiques provinciales dont l'hôte de
talent thériault et la même mélange est
une menace hypothétique pour justifier
son opposition et une cohérence sur cet
enjeu mais il a pas le monopole sur les
affaires bizarre parce que vous venez
d'entendre une pas mal vous aussi
je crois que justin trudeau le coup non
pas par le 3 secondes vous êtes entré de
dire que le gouvernement le goût se fait
l'instrument d'une tactique bloquistes
qui va soutenir la loi 21 pour faire
avancer le blog que le lendemain le bloc
va aller travailler avec les morts
et alors alors que mais la dernière fois
que j'ai vérifié le 21 octobre c'est
pour un référendum sa souveraineté son
élection fédérale où le bloc québécois
dit aux québécois n'envoyez pas avant
d'avoir des gens qui vont défaire ce que
vous avez demandé à ce que québec de
faire les choses que j'ai dit c'est que
vous prétendent être les meilleurs amis
de monsieur legault vous cacherais
jusqu'à madrid où cash flows
interventions actuelles pour le camp des
loges
alors pour vous pouvez réanimer le
mouvement souvent this le lendemain
après les élections le concentré à muret
la qualité de tous les crédits de
baisser les impôts de la vie plus
abordable
j'ai les doigts des palais oui donc la
question de loi 21 je pense que tous les
chefs ont le problème parce que tout le
monde dit que au niveau fera sauf pour
monsieur bingley que nous sommes contre
le loire mais en même temps on doit
respecter le québec et l'est que les
décisions de cours à 30 les décisions
des contestations et sont maintenant en
train au québec
voilà merci marc ameil on vous a laissée
par les questions en rafale
maintenant il ya été beaucoup beaucoup
question de cette histoire au cours des
derniers mois sur la scène politique
canadienne
alors je vous pose la même question à
tous souhaitez vous souhaitez vous un
accord de réparation pour snc lavalin
pour que l'entreprise je le rappelle
pour le bénéfice des gens la maison pour
que l'entreprise ne soit pas obligé
d'être condamné à ne plus recevoir s'il
ya une condamnation des contrats publics
pendant dix ans premier à répondre
monsieur bernier je suis nous sommes le
seul parti suis le seul chef qui a dit à
l'époque ya aucune corporation qui est
au dessus de la loi aucune entreprise
qui est au dessus de la loi donc le
gouvernement de monsieur trudeau 1
installé dans la législation canadienne
une clause qui permet d'avoir des
ententes spéciales avec des compagnies
corrompus nous ne sommes contre ce à
tous les compagnies doivent traiter de
la même façon snc lavalin comme les
autres et ça c'est très important parce
que si vous ne faites pas ça les
compagnies et les gens vont perdre
confiance dans notre système juridique
non nous les petites compagnies sont
poursuivis lorsqu'il arrive quelque
chose
les grandes salles aurait quand même
chose aussi très bien donc non monsieur
singh
c'est tellement difficile de dire ça
mais c'est ça va être la seule fois de
ma vie que je suis d'accord avec
monsieur bernier mai mais dans ce cas
oui il fallait un dernier débat
mais ce que je veux dire c'est oui c'est
que là le résultat de ce qui s'est passé
monsieur trudeau a essayé d'aider les
aider ces pdg par des travailleurs et
travailleuses ce qu'elle a dit en fait
elle est un premier ministre et ses
petits amis et rencontre les compagnies
et les aides
elle peut les appeler et dire et des
mois et dit oui qu'est ce que vous
voulez moi je suis pour les gens je vais
travailler pour les gens je veux
travailler pour les travailleurs
travailleuses
ça veut dire on a un système juste ce
qui est juste merci monsieur cei
monsieur trudeau presque tous pays
alliés en europe et ailleurs ou un
système d'entendre de réparation qui
permettent à une compagnie de payer des
pénalités de changer son comportement
sans punir les travailleurs qui n'avait
rien à faire avec les décisions des
hauts cadres c'est une situation qui
protège les travailleurs quand il ya de
la malfaisance au niveau d'une compagnie
c'est un système qui fonctionne à
travers le monde
mais la décision que si ça va être
donnée à une compagnie au canada
appartient uniquement au procureur
général et à au ministre de la justice
et nous allons respecter cette décision
attente elle sera prise monsieur
blanchet et beaucoup de choses à réparer
dans l'entente de réparation il faudra
réparer le mépris de monsieur trudeau
pour les institutions qui a fait plainte
une démarche qui aurait fonctionné même
s'il est exact que les grands pays
occidentaux en général ont de telles
ententes de réparation à même leur
propre législation
il faudra réparer la mauvaise habitude
le je vois que monsieur bernier s'ajoute
à ce que monsieur 500 ajoute à ça de
jouer le québec corrompus les 3400
employés de snc lavalin actuelle et la
direction actuelle de sensi la vallée
n'ont rien fait de pas correct
les actions tombe les morceaux vont être
vendus les travailleurs se cherche des
jobs et c'est un autre fleuron
d'ingénierie québécois qui va tomber à
cause de l'incurie ou de la mauvaise foi
des partis fédéraux merci monsieur
blanchet monsieur une fleuron de notre
pc l'indépendance de notre système
judiciaire et justin trudeau est cédée
ingéré dans le décision indépendante de
son procureur à écran et n'a pas obtenu
le résultat de décisions qui lui est là
lui congédié il a essayé d un gg et
nourrir notre système indépendant
judiciaire la décision doit rester avec
le procureur et c'est pas les excuses
des excuses des emplois et seulement une
jambe qui le premier s'est vu le sauver
et c'est là la de luiz razia la sienne
merci madame madame mais oui je suis
suis d'accord avec monsieur bernier
aucun cas être pris en aucune entreprise
ni personne n'est au-dessus de la loi
et c'est pour ça que je suis déçu avec
messieurs trop d'eau parce qu'il est
brisé la loi avec la pression contre
nature procureur général et en même
temps la même frange et loi omnibus que
j'ai palais sont tous les autres
sections c'est dans le même projet
omnibus bouge terre où ils ont changé le
code criminel pour aider el celler la
sanef ce n'est pas de façon merci les
décisions merci madame hermé débat
ouvert et comment je vous lance une
question et ensuite les réponses sont à
vous bien sûr sida c'est dans les crises
qu'on mesure le jugement et la
transparence d'un chef vous avez
tous ou à peu près tous dû passer
l'épongé sur des candidats dans certains
cas vous avez dû renvoyer les candidats
embarrassant à partir de maintenant est
ce que vous nous dites que c'est
tolérance zéro pour un candidat ou un
député éventuellement pour toute
remarque qu'ils seraient jugés racistes
monsieur blanchet bon je comprends très
bien pourquoi cette question là il a
aujourd'hui s'il n'importe laquelle des
candidats qui ont été mis en cause avait
refusé de s'excuser de façon explicite
et ne serait plus candidat du bloc parce
que je peux affirmer et je suis
convaincu que mes énormes réseaux
sociaux mon passé de chroniqueurs vont
passer aux ex tous ont été scrutés
personne ne peut douter que je souhaite
non importe quoi qu'il soit un petit peu
proche de raciste je n'aurais eu aucune
espèce de tolérance et je comprends que
les collègues et fait la même chose dans
un certain nombre de cas dans ce qui me
semble essentiel dans une campagne
électorale c'est que les gens
choisissent pour qui ils vont voter en
fonction des valeurs qui vont être
portés et c'est de ça dont il faut
parler de nous de tout coeur on va
travailler pour lequel a vu quatre
exemples des gens qui ont dû s'excuser
mais ce chien aussi monsieur trudeau
aussi monsieur à l'isi je peux vous dire
qu'il ya une candidats qui ne jamais
être passé de notre système notre
processus pour pour analyser les
candidats c'est le canada qui a brisé la
loi sur l'éthique deux fois c'est une
canada qui a menti souvent qui a bondi
de
beaucoup des choses dans sa vie et ça
c'est le candidat libéral de papineau se
trudeau les excuses sont importants mais
les gestes et les intentions et les
valeurs sont importantes aussi on va
toujours jugé selon quelques les
priorités les valeurs et les actions de
tous et de chacun
ça fait partie du choix électoral que
les gens font est ce que les gens
représentent leur valeur ils sont là
pour les dix défendre et je pense que
les gens savent que depuis quatre ans je
les défends et on va continuer d'avancer
en les défendant ne sommes pas parfaits
je ne suis pas parfait des candidats ont
fait des erreurs
l'important c'est que les candidats
assument ces erreurs là et si au lieu à
des excuses oui c'est parfait mais après
ça après ça on doit s'assurer que ces
gens là partagent les valeurs
canadiennes les valeurs d'équité de
liberté de tolérance et c'est ce qui est
important pour nous notre parti est
fondée sur des principes clairs l'équité
la tolérance et le respect et on veut
que nos candidats fassent la même chose
et ils le font très bien monsieur singh
donc c'est en fait c'est une question
d'authenticité
donc si quelques s'excuse mais ne
s'engage pas d'échangé pour l'avenir il
n'y a pas un engagement fort et faire
des choses différement dont non mais si
c'est un fait qui s'excuse et aussi un
engagement d'échangé est aussi en fait
six cas qui partagent nos valeurs
elle va rester dans la partie nos
valeurs c'est de travailler travailler
pour les gens pas pour les produits
nos valeurs sont de travail pour
défendre les droits de la personne nos
valeurs sont des vraiment avancer la
justice sociale en même temps qu'on
combat contre la crise climatique
on peut le faire ensemble c'est
exactement les sortes candidats équipe
on a et c'est exactement cela les nazis
ont besoin
nous avons un problème dans notre de
marcos et j'ai plusieurs gens qui m'a
demandé pourquoi que quelqu un qu un
citoyen a présenté pour un parti dont
notre démarque aussi dans les élections
parce qu'il ya toujours les choses qui
sont intéressés mais pour moi même c'est
une question les niveaux de leurs
commentaires
nous avons dont le parti vers zéro
tolérance vers racisme antisémitisme
sexisme
c'est clair mais on doit réfléchir parce
que 16
l'action dans les dernières quelques
semaines nous avons pris le temps la
grande majorité du temps avec les petits
politique pas dans le dialogue pour
aider tout le monde de trouver les
façons de travailler ensemble contre
agences thématiques et avait jusqu'à
mach dernière souffle je vais arrêter
les émeutiers faut travailler ensemble
il faut qu'on fasse un bon choix il faut
qu'on avance pour lutter contre les
changements climatiques et on va
continuer ainsi
monsieur chez un petit mot monsieur
blanchet un petit mot et nous concluons
ensuite alors le choix cette élection
c'est clair ces quatre autres années
avec les hausses d'impôts la vie qui
devient plus cher ou une pratique
considérée avec moi qui va rendre les
biens ou le marché 10 secondes
on savait au parlement on voit trop fort
ce qui est bon pour le québec votre
compte qu'ils m'avaient pour le québec
merci lire pour le biais mesdames et
messieurs merci madame mais sur les
chefs merci à vous dans l'ensemble vous
avez été disciplinés merci 21 octobre
jour du vote mesdames et messieurs c'est
un rendez vous donc pour la grande
soirée électorale sur toutes les
plateformes que radio canada
merci de votre attention merci à toute
l'équipe derrière à la prochaine
[Applaudissements]